all right and we are live welcome to the
last word with Lord Cognito and abates
hot by the campfire toasty destiny
discussion how are you doing mr. the I'm
call you the Lord of the Internet well
now anyway
Wow no God I hope so but ya know I wish
I was Lord of the Internet I wouldn't
have had the issues I've had for the
last two weeks so I don't know if you
guys caught the video or the live stream
last week I should say video should have
been fine I have been having some
internet upload speed issues and
consistency and streaming so anybody who
watches this thing anywhere you find me
I'm sorry about that I did a test stream
on like YouTube for like 10 minutes and
somebody was like hey it just popped
onto the stream and then you were gone I
was like it was a test
it literally said tested in the title
I'm sorry but I've been trying
everything and then I had and I had my
ISP come out a few days ago like checked
everything in the house check the lines
it was like in the middle of the
afternoon usually when I wasn't having
the issues had a guy come out last night
at like he got here at like 8:00 the
dude got here late when it was supposed
to be bad but like two hours before he
got here
mm-hmm internet goes down for like five
minutes was like huh and then came back
on and I was like let me keep running
speed tests cuz I was like doing test
streams that were crap all night
dropping frames here and there after
that happened rock-solid mmm like I was
testing higher bitrate than I usually do
like running or lands at the same time
which definitely will tax the computer
everything not one not not an iota of a
drought frame not one not even like all
right 25 here or like a little blip
above a hundred because I'm getting like
five hundred thousand two thousand huge
chunks of just dropped frames massive
sometimes so magic behind the scenes or
if somebody did something it and tell me
so I don't know but I'm gonna just
hopefully cross their fingers and go
with it so I've been having internet
issues and sporadic Borderlands play
what even up to yeah just been grinding
man I've been um I thought that I saw
that grind ha ha ha got my lord reg
Rick's done finally on PC so I could say
it's done now a PC so I'm very happy
but um yeah just been it's weird I
thought I was gonna take more time or
from destiny
prior to shadow key but then I got in
this pocket of having the best possible
weapons that I'm missing and regex was
one you know I'm very you know obviously
last week we talked about the pulse meta
so uh I'm banking on reg Nick's
benefiting from this I was like let's
get it done that's a grand man it's no
God is it ever was
yeah yes it was a grind man so it's
doing that um still what else I was
working so much oh I was helping out
kibosh out the kibosh on descendants I
was helping him out without break
perfect it now it's fine to see that
experience going through it and
everything again and again and Trevor
moment it just fine like you just smile
how could you not laugh like Oh fine man
just the whole thing about it I can't
wait for the next one of those cuz I
know yeah we'll get to it we have a
dungeon like shadow thrones big thing
coming but like little secrets those are
those are still special - yeah man but
yeah sure I got the register and then
last what I'm working on now is um I
gotta get my Izanami catalyst so I am
actively recruiting heroic menagerie
players man I gotta get it done man did
you get you catalyst oh you didn't
borrow that now says I did not cuz the
first time I finished heroic once but my
chalice is done so I need to do that
once to hear about the flawless as much
just crossing the finish line yeah same
thing I don't care about flawless I just
again my whole mentality is the best
possible weapons leading in the shadow
key I want to have versatility and every
position and everything and and also
doing my mods got my mods out I had to
break down rest in peace to my arm
taking armament or class item but I had
to break you down brac because I need to
I need to UM the mod to be loose in my
remember if you only have one copy was
it all you said case I don't know
in the ding so I wouldn't play I would I
wouldn't take no chances man I don't
just say an armor is not gonna matter
those aren't gonna go in the new armor
that's true too but I wonder what how do
you gonna handle it so like is you just
you can put the armor mods an old armor
but those aren't gonna matter you can
use them up or recently got you yeah so
yes yeah you can use them on old armor
but they're not gonna go in new armor so
if they nevins like if you want to like
take something into it mm-hmm but yeah
that's the other that's the weapons you
need to keep a one of each yes and
somehow I have one last wish like twice
and I have taken spec what yeah the
takin spec increased damage against
taking enemies it's just like it's a
weapon mod and like one of the few
random weapon mods I think that are out
there so okay I looked and I was like
and I've got just about everything so I
can break down everything but one I
don't think I have to farm for much
they're lucky yeah I got my second
rampage spec orders unite now here baby
so I'm ready I'm ready to go so that's
been pretty much it it's been a lot of
that and um yeah man we got a lot to
talk about so I'll keep it short on that
but um I'm ready man it's the grind
never stops I am ready for shadow Keith
we got a lot to talk about
well we got a hell of a grind coming
we're gonna start at the Vidocq go
through pieces of that if you guys in
chat have any thoughts from the viaduct
we'll try and go through it it's all
over the place on that thing so we'll
probably jump around a bit as well
then we're going to talk about the
seasons and then we'll get into the tois
a couple pieces of info tidbits that
dropped in there as well
but the season ranks I know will
definitely go through if you guys
haven't seen the images floating around
you can see all hundred levels so we all
know what's in there
and the biggest thing is the Vidak so we
have a whole whole lot more to talk
about when it comes to those things yeah
what from the Vidocq first like stood
out the most you what you see what you
get a feel any teasers that came like
what because I went through this thing
frame by frame so I've looked at it yeah
you comb through that bad boy I'm like a
screenshot in this what's happening for
me man I mean I it was probably one of
the better Vioxx you know and um I was a
lot of fields for I don't know it's
something
by just the way it was done the way it
was shot at the studio and then I just
loved you know the combination of how
seasons are gonna evolve and I love the
fact that you're gonna get everything
with that narrative cohesion pretty much
I can plug plug plug just wrote about
this and loads of gaming that net but um
yeah man I am really really feeling
bungees direction here and I'm super
excited you know we have you know it
broke it down and what shadow keeps
gonna do you know season of the undying
the the new mechanics the nightmare and
we're talking about you know PvP
improvements but I think ultimately what
excited me the most was just the
cohesion of seasons to season and Luke
Smith saying things like look you know
you're gonna have moments like man you
should have been there when such a
stretch was happening and you know that
kind of thing so um yeah I did I'm
excited I'm excited you know I think
that in the future I mean in the past
they probably might not have been able
to do this kind of thing and I just
loved them having their whole
independence and just saying look this
is what that she's gonna become and also
want to talk about obviously the big
rumor that's going on right now is the I
know you screenshot at that bulletin
board say then you can go for no no I
was gonna say that can be a rumor that
cannot they can still have a plan but
still transition into it in a different
way I know everybody's like oh no it's
not I'm like whether it is or isn't they
have a plan and there's a easy ways to
see a board and there you can they could
do I'm not saying the rhobar noticed but
they can honestly take it either way you
could be looking at it be like oh what
year is this and that may be the year it
goes from one to the next and it's like
it's still gonna be the same path but so
let's let's discuss for the people who
might not know all right
first coming grains of salt or heavy in
here here we go let's go let's get to it
break it down you said you're the one
who's flaunting this rumor out here just
wait I'll wind like this I'm just
talking about people freaking out
because of again Eden in the scene about
the five-minute mark of the video of the
vid by doc
they talk about you know they have a
bull about saying hey it's season of the
dying season or whatever then dawn or
what's the next one dawn isn't about
just season them see them dawn right so
basically people are freaking out
because as you look at this board it
still continues
you know season of them whatever and you
a lot of stuff is illegible but the fear
from the community is that they whip
this new season format they are gonna
commit to just staying on destiny two or
five years because they counted you know
the years down in their head and
according to the board and people are
concerned like oh man you know there's
not gonna be any destiny three and you
know tomorrow my response to it is let's
be real like are they gonna put destiny
three on this board for you to see like
that's how I looked at my close to vest
they're not stupid they know guys like
us
Ibanez is gonna take this thing well
they only put up what in there they want
you to see exactly you know they only
gonna show you what they want to show
you so that's why I'm not getting crazy
I am firmly convinced again like I said
my article there will be a desti three
at some point it may not be maybe it's
not as early as we think no but at some
point I feel it's gonna come and um yeah
I think it would just come at a time
with they're comfortable making either a
transition if it's like hey we do a lot
of fighting in our solar system over the
next Lake year and a half or two years
and then it finally that's the point
we'll be like okay late our solar system
is toast and we got to go off and it's
like in it and it gives you a reason to
move the story forward but also a reason
to transition to I mean something major
like that is what I would see I mean and
for me some people are like oh well what
about things that you know people say
they could only do me like there are
certain things that I see in a destiny
three that I would like and there's
certain things I don't know if they can
truly switch the architecture of the
game enough to make it work without
doing a destiny three and things like
cross play
things like dedicated servers
ding-ding-ding I mean those are big
pieces that I see but those are like
architecture of howl destiny to is built
from the ground up from the code IRA not
a coder I'm not a programmer I'm not a
developer I'm not a systems engineer I'm
none of those things so maybe they can't
build that stuff in the background but I
have a hunch that would be a lot harder
as opposed to clean slates build it up
try this again like exactly and you
could use your API data to be like
you've been through these things weather
guns carry who knows but like they would
have a way to kick you off into a new
infrastructure and I think that would be
those are the things I think d3 when
they do it needs to be done right so if
it takes a little longer and it yeah and
that's what I'm saying when you see year
4 year 5 year 6 years 7 you're like yeah
that's just years of destiny and they
still had 10 years of destiny one
planned we're sitting in destiny 2 now
because because marketing choices and
stuff like that and so and back then
when we were looking at the slides and
it had comment and then it had all stuff
or whatever I guess massive did we see
destiny 2 written in big letters let
know again people thought they just need
to calm down it's fine if they're gonna
do things at the timetable that they're
ready you know I'm saying and right now
in a good spot so I'm not worried about
it in the least and I'm with you also
d3 would be great also from the
standpoint like you said infrastructure
wise new engine and let's be real cuz I
got it I got a confession it I've been
doing this cross a man it's like doing
the Lord's work going down to that
console boy voice I don't care I'm still
not that wrong I don't blame you I'm
gonna tell you right now this is
literally a laborer above to be playing
I'll play sure you're loving it while
you do it Lord Frey did you kill other
people's playing away and I'm just so
the frame facing it it just oh it's just
all over the place and no field of view
and PC and my respect that's why
destiny 3 definitely needs to happen at
some point
because castle guys I know for your eyes
you think you're fine but when you've
come through the mountains you see what
destiny could be and then you go down
and you see that you I mean and okay
that's the point of multiple things more
people if they ever play at 144 frames
which I don't even do whenever I'm a
that transition will be in a difference
even for me it's the general nature of
ignorance is bliss with anything that's
what it is and not to say like it's a
stupid level it's not ignorance it's
just unknowing like if you have an eye
on PC I haven't seen this before so if
you have friends that play on PC don't
go look at it unless you're getting
ready to build one because then you're
just gonna really get the itch and want
to build one and want a bill on and
again full disclosure 4k HDR it looks
great still it would put it this way I
had to in order for me to tolerate it I
had to pick up an SSD 4x4 my xbox what X
I was like just look just opening a menu
to change gears I'm like brah when a we
get when can I get into my menu loading
I'm getting sandwiches I'm going taking
bath room bags I'm still not in the
match so I'm like it's funny the people
in PC a joke that they're a lot less
productive in real life now that they're
on PC shout at the par 5 so I should
move over to my PC from ps4 listen part
lion have you're capable if you're
capable I say by all means now we'll say
one negative thing I know I've been
console bashing now I got a PC bash now
I got it oh very fair there it's fair
now this is why I do it still and I
still play over there shut across save
is because again if you're not the
nightfall champion the the soloist
extraordinaire that we have here ends on
where your people play with us there you
can see right is it again cuz with PC
chatting community aspect you know
getting multiple thing like again I'm
trying to get my nose redone I can get
that done on console like this cuz you
it's just you have people don't know
saying you have people though like what
if I'm just like I put up my ps4 and I'm
like I still don't have anybody to play
with on ps4 it's not better on either
side for me for that
I will I will say this Xbox I'm gonna be
a little biased the Xbox has it a little
bit better set up because they have in
oh I have a Nui lfg built in so you just
press the Xbox Live button and you
literally say boom destiny boom boom
this is what I want to do real quick and
you're getting requests but if you can
get stuff done so that that's what I'm
saying
community wise it's a little easier to
get bigger activities done that's what I
would say cuz I gotta be honest when I'm
in PC and broke shut up don't scream I'm
a shot my boy with homescreen shall
descend there's a bit of times we just
sitting there we eating it load into
management like there's no population so
tell it's smaller it's like yeah coming
up soon it'll play will change so roll
easy we're sitting in a little bit like
oh are we gonna get anybody for Coke
today top is harder yeah yeah in
fairness I just got to keep it fair for
my console dues oh I have to get you all
the way so that's all I guess yeah I
wanted to take a quick step back though
said Fred had a question earlier and he
was asking so if you have a perfectly
rolled piece of armor and this is
something to address when I'm like
prepping for shadow keep whether it's
gonna be a video I put together but the
general idea is people are wondering
should I clean up my vault what should I
get rid of what should I keep armor mods
are only gonna work in old armor they
will not work in year 3 armor but thank
you for that being said old armor if you
have say I have a pair of gauntlets that
has machine guns scavenger and machine
gun reload her like damn good role for
machine guns that are still pretty
usable mm-hmm hold on to it yes now do I
need a random one that has like a chest
Pete I swear every chest piece can
probably go yeah most chess pieces suck
anyway they mostly have what it's like
primary ammo finders and crap like that
this chest their trash like if you have
something good keep it if you have an
exotic that has a great roll on it
you're like hey I don't know if I'm
gonna get a decent stat roll on this
exotic you can pull the exotic and find
out if you do but you're gonna at least
have a base set of stat rules and then
those perks should still be there
whether it's mmm you know sniper
scavenger sniper reloader you know
snipers are stuff like
there are certain things you can't
probably go through and keep but there's
a lot you can get rid of if there's a
certain loadout you're like hey let me
keep a couple loadouts for my one main
character that I'm probably gonna go
with don't need like 50 Helms of every
type because I've got like grenade
launcher loaders Kevin's your linear
fusion loader and scavenger like most of
that stuff's gonna get replaced mm-hmm
so only keep the stuff that's likely to
be like your prime rolls don't be like
oh this is like heavy ammo finder it's
like it's not gonna matter like a lot of
stuff is not going to matter now weapons
on the other hand that's what's still
gonna matter those are what's gonna
carry this to bay a sandbox will change
things like that so if you have a decent
amount of weapons you might like parse
it down some mm-hmm bleh yeah you're
still probably keep a decent variety
because we don't know what's gonna be
the good stuff so if you're like me I'll
keep more weapons but I'm gonna wipe a
lot of armor yeah absolutely I've been
doing that you nailed it I think from me
I'm only gonna hold on to what I
consider my synergistic like rolls again
with armor like you say when you got to
you know I've been running this allow me
a lot lately so I've been you know the
sniper rifle Reserve scavenger that'll
be my purse that potential with that
patch come in - yeah man it gonna be
real nasty yeah that right there and
then um yeah like I told you earlier
I've just been farming for like the best
stuff and all shout out I forgot to
mention got my Imperial decree with
trench barrel y'all I'm set no good the
synthetic baby I'm good and don't sleep
on it in PvP yeah what a range master
work nice yeah but like I gotta shut up
I'm gonna shout out a couple people by
the way on Monday put it out on Twitter
that it needed to finish at Corona
sorrel the thing was done in 46 minutes
Wow GT crowd assignments yeah we knocked
that thing out so fast
shout out - it was yolk blue course
lemon Kevin and Connie all five of those
I literally threw out on Twitter like
the next day is like hey when I get home
from work need to knock this out last
day of moments of triumph got it and got
it it's just like done minutes literally
whole thing not like a checkpoint walked
in the door
straight through mmm real quick real
quick give me your cuz you know we do
you know we do our raid discussions here
we knock
go with the overall just your experience
of not in comparison to other rings but
just what was your feel of Cronus Ohm's
chaos it's a lot of chaos mainly because
it is the whole mechanics switching
thing yeah benders over there like after
we spent hours on that first encounter
on day one yeah we were on that first
encounter for a long time and we did
that first encounter I think I died
twice and they still kept it going so
yeah they were no it was it's the whole
got to be in this place shoot this thing
and switch and it's you know then you
got to be in the shield and then if
you're punching but I'm punching just to
the left of the crystal because it
doesn't like auto tracker there's
certain moments there's a lot of things
that can go wrong I mean if you if you
run like an oiled machine I mean
obviously people burn through it because
they did I was still there but it's cool
but also we did like the wheel it we won
fazed him we just absolutely wrecked him
because I think just about everybody had
swarms so he was toast oh he was slay I
mean everybody had to Boop somebody had
to Boop with it to the Boop and the sand
the swarms yeah oh he was he was dead so
fast it didn't when as soon as the
damaged face popped up toast like wow I
think we hit we died on him we talked
about for like five minutes died on him
like once or twice mm-hmm because I was
kind of getting the hang of like where
to go and win and then when we finally
actually got the full cycles done
smashed the deception and when went for
full damage phase is is just he was dead
he was so dead so fast though cool
little thing though the jumping puzzle
was different because you kind of had to
split up one guy like what is that sword
from Mars but let's see people like fly
with that thing now with the hawk float
war line world line zero Lorelei zero
yes yes I think like he went over to a
chain
climbed up a chain was waiting on the
other side before we even started the
encounter so he was just helping shoot
stuff and there's a way with mountaintop
when any of the crystals are in the
bubbles and if you hit the top of the
bubble or towards the top with
mountaintop this the Splash Damage will
actually tag the crystal so you don't
even have to be like in it like you're
supposed to be people mountain it's like
people have found so much stuff about
that thing it's like it's it's a joke 18
broccoli II that's was so yeah they were
they were solid so shoutouts all you
guys if you ever listen to this one
thank you guys that was that was about
as easy as I could ask for it came home
I was like alright I got a couple hours
before my wife and I get home we're
gonna work out and maybe try it later I
got home we were done with the raid and
I was like she's not gonna be home for
like two hours five yes we are here
about yeah we got so no we can talk
about it mhm
yeah overall I mean it's fun the raid0
is cool it isn't all that long honestly
you got the open you got the opening
lighting the lanterns you jump and
you're in the last room and both things
are in the last room so it's literally
first room jumping and then last room
and you do to set two things in the last
room with the deception and stuff but
yeah yeah I mean it was it was quick but
it was cool doesn't have it doesn't have
the weight to me of like the big ones we
always talk about it's not you're a
Larry yeah well yeah it's shorter that's
why I'm like I'm hoping shadow keeps
rate it's like solid long feeling
lengthy mean he cool thing so no that's
kind of good to have that one under the
belt just to get a feel for it before we
go into what's next so back back to you
though can I did cut you I don't know
you're gonna on Vidak
yep what did you feel when you saw this
valley like what where were you at with
any standouts for you my you kind of
touched on it but I guess mine would be
a slight variation is the connecting
arcs of the story for me sounds it I've
got to see it in action
so everybody can take that with a grain
of salt be like oh you're gonna have a
cool connecting story like it has it has
so much potential it's all about seeing
it in action though you could be like
hey we're gonna have these arcs season 8
connects to season 9 we're gonna have
the vex offensive we've got the final
offensive we close the vex offensive
down something's left over kicks off
season of dawn then we go into that
we're doing this thing the nines going
on then that goes into 10 11 is crazy
going into the next year sounds
absolutely freaking not like awesome
thank you yeah but yeah I was like have
you seen action how's the plague how's
the connection how's the writing is the
events cool like is the final offensive
just more so that yes yeah they've got
to prove it but in theory that sounds
that sounds like what they wanted to do
and this is kind of something it sounds
like what they wanted to do the whole
time and this was what I wanted to ask
you is like when they say hey we have a
ten-year plan
did did capital our reasons come
knocking on the door and be like hey we
got to start putting numbers on these
things into expansions do you think what
they like I mean do you think this has
been more of a learning of what they've
been through to trying or do you think
this is like the point to where they
finally are allowed to do what they want
to do I think it's a combination of
things I think it's two parts one less
be real from the very beginning they
were picking up the pieces almost like
they had a finished book scrapped it got
torn to pieces and then they were
literally piece mailing and patched me
you know a broken product to just get to
launch we all know the story shout out
to Jason Schreyer you know I'm saying
who's put that out in his books you know
bless went put in pixels it what destiny
one was a mess just to get launched it
is amazing the game even came to be what
it was so that's one then you get then
Luke was around during that era you know
Sam well that's so talked about it and
kind of funny when he was saying like
vaulted glass wasn't even really
supposed to be they were supposed to be
like crota and then the backside of
kurtal that we've never even seen going
into Kings like that was also needs to
be like one connected thing and we get
it like over an expansion in the next
year's total release and crazy as
they're like oh that's so weird
yeah man so again that's how I look at
destiny one dusty two-wheeled we know
the history on how I started yada yada
you know they made the gross
miscalculation of making it you know a
fashion game and casual game and we know
story but now I look at it like okay you
that those use with a learning
experience to get the game to where it
needed to because shout out to didn't we
have recently to taken King anniversary
recently yeah I want to shot that I
think yeah we had the ticket again yeah
we have taking anniversary and to me
that was the representation of what
destiny was really supposed to be that
was like the right the right path then
you know we got forsaken or so now I
think it's like they're in pocket it's
just now we don't got Big Brother over
us right
Big Brother trying to really press us
like hey you got to release this at this
cadence at that time because let's be
real I know it's only was it two weeks
with the shadow keep delay or whatever
we know it was yeah
that was a significant thing and again
I'm worried about my article um I don't
think old Bungie would have been allowed
to do that because the reality is they
were underneath the Activision umbrella
they've got all that assembly line stuff
going on so if you push destiny out of
September like Activision the perfect
world says yeah you stay in September
because I don't want you messing with my
Call of Duty and all these other things
and overlapping they I don't think they
would have a lot so to me that's a big
deal and now it's like I don't want
again you said it perfectly I don't we
they have to execute right it sounds
great but it it sounds exciting
it sounds like the destiny that we
wanted you know I'm saying like why are
we going here right what do we they even
said it some of those some of the death
they were like you know we want to give
you a reason why did we do this right
even in the Luke Smith um director's cut
how he reinvasion of murray with the new
season evolution like oh yeah is what I
was talking about
cuz you were
but that was my biggest beef with black
I'm like who is this chick why is he
here how she just show up like what's
going on like you know say like it so
weakly done narrative Wow now we like
the content but I just didn't like the
way it was presented if this is executed
right this could be special so that's
where I'm at
yeah I mean for me that's the big one is
for like the arc going through if they
actually connect the stories and season
of dawn dawning it's probably it's gonna
be what does it everybody say like
December 10th is the date that that
would be launching so you got the
dawning event that'll actually probably
kick off season have dawn be kind of
curious what happens no wonder when
we'll see your dude yeah I guess some
dairies and my boy Josh reading though
tremendous honor he's gonna have me so
excited from a dude so let's see some
point yes no so yeah I mean those that's
my big one is probably the arcing story
that has potential because at least four
new because what you've talked about
armor we've seen weapon changes we've
seen those types of things
what else did you see in there whether
it was like is there any little tidbits
are there no screens any frames let's go
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna be honest II
imma steal your thunder bro I can't
believe I must say this but that dungeon
fear OH
that first of all aesthetically it looks
fantastic yet no disrespect just up to
my aesthetics that one's amazing I'm
just a fiction this is not true
shattered throne slander this is jazz we
know it the gray I feel you I feel you
like shatter throne is amazing we're not
gonna be disrespectful all I'm saying it
the aesthetic of this do shadow keep
done [ __ ] it's more my speed like this
that red and the hues and the castle
then you going mean you got the you're
weaving and it it's just look don't like
it I just like the way look when you see
in the Big Shot the pyro gave me an
amazing - did you see that
oh dude that's a boss that's what I'm
told I want my cycle it's like a molten
lava night yeah bro this with a giant
fire sword good bro he had that yo who
don't lift out here which Harvey do you
yeah do you even lift bro
let's go like that's what I'm talking
like one thing about this okay so let me
stop you right there first that was good
no I don't want them to show me stuff
like that oh I don't you got bad I think
like if I'm now in no one at some point
I'm gonna face the dude like whether
he's the middle like the ogre whether
he's the Dylan karu mm-hmm at some point
now we know we're gonna see that guy I'm
like show me the jumping puzzle show me
a shadow of something you could show me
a silhouette of him and be like hey
there's a big giant knight in there but
don't show me that he's covered in
molten fire with a flaming sword leave
that till I walk in and I have that and
I have a holy crap moment there there
are times I know they want to hype the
game and I know they're doing it for
marketing but leave that part out but
you just I look at it to UM you I agree
with you overall I think they got a
little too excited yeah they know they
got so here we go show them this like
yeah that's a major there's like the
dungeon is two major bosses yeah one of
them I don't know
oh the shadow throne had to major
because he had the ogre fight and the
Dolan card night and wizard like crazy
fire mm-hmm two majors the build up the
jumping the descent all that stuff was
there mm-hmm if there's say if it's a
similar build out or what if that's just
the one main boss you fight and I've
seen him now
nah they can't do that now you got it
okay what if he's the big one and
there's a medium one but everything I'm
still or is the big night where's the
big night okay this guy's kind of big
but where's the blank now I'm always
anticipating that I set an expectation
like all right where do I see it now if
I walk in and see him and that's where I
begin that'll be that'll throw me that's
what I'm saying but I doubt that let's
just say that I doubt we I feel like
they're saving that for a little bigger
we've had this discussion at the launch
of forsaken when they showed cave dead
and you went bonkers you were like this
is sacrilegious and I'm like II I feel
you but they gotta sell this bad boy
they gotta sell it
and what happened we got the Tremont
city that we didn't know about I mean
not you dungeon that you didn't know
what we know about legit now I know
about one of the bosses oh my god
it's even more so hot you know what sue
mom what you know I would but I'm with
you I'm the same way when I love
something so much don't show me nothing
I know that sent to me and I get that
sent to me trust me yes that's what I
got with you me that that thing the
dungeon man it really did nightmare
hunts team cool yeah for all of those
look at you like jumping puzzles I'm
sorry cuz you're gonna hate this one it
looks like but what I can't find there's
one mmm some people are gonna hate the
hell out of this I can already tell you
so you're falling down a tunnel and
you've got like the two spinning tubes
of spiky death yeah a technical term by
the way as you like there's one point
also it looks like the spinning tubes
are like moving through like a valley or
a corridor and there's like swing lamps
and I'm like oh my god if you have to
jump on the swinging lamps and you'll
figure that flawlessly I'm gonna be like
plucking so hard over here oh my god yo
shadow my boy likes man flu gang we in
trouble yeah just like touch and go man
touch and go
spitting tubes of spiky death yeah
that's that's the official name coin
directly run away I'm sure and but I'm
sure bungees back there if any of you
ever listened to us by the way thank you
and also I'm sorry at the same time but
I'm sure that's exactly what the
designers like spinning tubes is like a
death yes totally sure that's what they
are calls like completely on that that
white boy sir yeah hundred percent do a
lot of stuff look so cool I'm just I'm
height man one thing about bungee man
ain't know how to sell a product and
dungeon was definitely a highlight
yep so we got a couple other pieces from
it we now know about nightfall V ordeal
so between this and nightfall Nightmare
hunts though
crossed a few times I'm sure all of
those have a lot of difficulties and by
a lot I mean more than we've ever had
ever
mm-hmm we have a debt we have here we
have legend we have master and now we
know the light level of Master it's nine
eighty nine sixty to my knowledge is the
gear cap is the gear cap yes your boat
you have to get your bonus power mm-hmm
above that just to go venture into the
highest difficulty mm and gears not even
gonna come easy in the first place like
you might start to get up to like 950 if
you're raiding or doing in-game stuff
951 952 bonus powers getting you there
it's like they're gonna start to work
but man 980 s well when you look at what
its gonna have modifiers and this is for
so this is a new this has to be one of
the new strikes hmm but the mission
modifiers empath champions unstoppable
barrier equipment will be locked match
game chafe is back apparently champions
mob champions mob and hash Linton's
serenade mmm this sound crazy
that's so much stuff that's a lot of
stuff to do it's a really painful
nightfall man like solo nightfall is
gonna be like where's your soul the
night field now be like I'm over it
I'm in the corner crying in the fetal
position in essence it's like I got this
this looks serious look serious but I
will say I love the reward listing
alright so we're gonna go through those
well so at legend and this is bizarre by
the way cuz I never expected to see this
on a knife roll or exotic gear comin and
this is legend so this is 950 and then
enhancement prisms those are taking you
from level seven of level seven of armor
to eight and nine you need the prisms
principle resumes to eight and nine and
then 10 the ascendant shard is how you
get to max your armor mmm so at Master
difficulty we get exotic gear common
enhancement prisms common and then
ascendant shards uncommon mmm
that pinnacle activity grind for said
static oh yeah I don't know it has a
weird so weird determination to have
common in parentheses next to exotics oh
okay this is what I of it I don't get
that I'm like sitting here trying to
think something up but I was like my
only thought on common is with relation
to stats yes that's the only thing I can
even that doesn't sound yeah said
friends like exotic gear quote common
that doesn't sound good that doesn't
sound like a feeling I mean yeah we want
exotics but why do I want a common dicks
is this like old exotics we can get or
get out indoors just think about that
play are there stat all right I don't is
if the chance at a drop in there that
you're just getting you have it you have
a high common chance that exotic in a
Senate chart is uncommon in there and
you can rerun this thing mm-hmm
maybe that's like your odds at getting
it versus well if you got if that level
of that common has to be it almost feels
guarantee drop ish right I mean yeah it
sounds like it's you have a pretty good
chance of getting an exotic clay yeah
like I was think so so and to me that's
kind of like what I fell in love with d1
when the night fall meant something I
mean I'm not saying you know I'm know
people still I'll be Ozzie like I've
really cooled our night falls in d2 I
just don't do them it's something about
the setup in at much forum there's
really not that I mean the points don't
what is it whose line is it anyway the
show where the questions are made up in
the points don't matter the points don't
matter in night falls like I mean there
is I think you can almost speed or on a
night fall and get a special emblem if
you speedrun every night fall in a
season but really the points once you've
done your triumphs or whatever they
don't do next to them they say they give
you a higher chance I think get like
whatever exclusive is in there but I
don't care about those anyway so it's
like without the strike specific I mean
they still have some things but again
it's just one of those things that I've
lost a lot of interest and discounts of
seeing or which got a reward structure
per tier yeah that excites me
that excites me a bit because now it's
like okay you know I need these shards
you know I'm saying oh I need whatever
right and that kind of was gonna get me
to go in there you know if that's gonna
give me the ascent value I gotta do it
this is a guaranteed source you know
that's where I am with this exotic I
don't know yeah that's I gotta
understand that one later yeah the other
thing we see is champions unstoppable
and champions barrier those are the two
modifiers that we knew about going into
the hunts Nightmare hunts have these you
see the like Knight champions they one
of those pictures I have a screenshot of
a knight that has like the barrier piece
around his head just looks cool I've got
a couple screenshots that are just sick
um those are very much artifact mods no
seasonal artifact mods being used in
night falls hmm see where I'm going with
that break that repeat that one sighs
okay
so in the artifact your mods they're
gonna help you fight these unstoppable
champions or barrier champions or
whatever it is those mods at least am i
understanding unless they're gonna drop
somewhere else or coming from the
artifact ah so then the question lies
seasonal artifact ends at the end of the
season right Falls are still a thing
those aren't going anywhere right and
the nightmare hunts as well so is it
like are we gonna get a new artifact
that always has champions unstoppable
barrier and there's the third one and I
can remember it now is it just gonna be
a different set of weapons is it gonna
be a different set of modifiers on those
guys like this is where when you go into
it looks like they're in the arcology on
titan doing the Sabbath in song or you
have that opening section and there's
just a giant big giant like unstoppable
ogre in there I was like all right
that's gonna be a problem like he's just
part of the nightfall now yeah it was
like they're adding enemies two strikes
for what so you'll see in municipal
places so you'll play through and all of
a sudden here's a mini crazy boss man
means you have to take out as well yes
on top of everything else so that's
where I don't know how the seasons
transition is gonna go because the
artifact I mean that second column of
the artifact is all about these
modifiers
so are they always gonna be like
unstoppable barrier or is it gonna be
different or is it just gonna be
different weapon types I have a lot of
questions much to say genius a good
question there's a good question I mean
don't know how they're gonna handle it
but I do see what you mean in reference
to those new you know champions or enemy
types being littered around is they're
almost to me taking the place of like
once I almost like wanted 2.0 you know
sedan so dad dad survived I'm getting
you know from everything so yeah if you
go to the modifier it's this so you
could say alright it's gotta be
champions and stuff and Barry alright
guys switch out my mods I gotta get this
oh okay I'm really gonna switch it up
alright yeah man so nightfall is gonna
be rough
yeah I'm nine eighty is gonna be work to
get to by the way that is some fifty
tonight we got a lot to go man oh so
you've got overload unstoppable and
barrier because I finally found the
mixture of the overload Minotaur and it
does look like almost carrot like I
guess I would say enemies specific like
unstoppable ogres overload minotaurs and
then barrier Knights are the ones I
typically keep seeing like those
specific like class enemies fit that
modifier so at least you might have an
idea what you're gonna be fighting if
you see you're like okay Knights I got
to deal with this type of shield and
this weapon and this bergeron and that
type of stuff so we'll see if it's
predictable but mm-hmm
so far seems at least somewhat
consistent yeah mmmm
oh my screenshots of the dungeon can't
wait for that one beautiful what else
from the Vidocq because i go throw my
screenshots and look yeah man for me
also I got let's talk about it man
captain PvP right here so I'm just like
oh well not just bro and I said your map
I can't think of Twilight gap was
something else this Twila am I thinking
of rusted lands where there's like side
sea side a you've got the baby tunnel in
the middle and yeah
is that rusted Lance I think that's rust
okay my mind I thought twilight gap was
it's fine it's definitely a closer
quarters one you have a couple little
her boxes which I still hate like head
sniping but it's definitely a lot more
close quarters you got the feel like the
two side tunnels it's not like and then
like be out on its own little box like
out there on the side oh yeah it's it's
tighter for sure but they got widows
Court which is closer so I guess they're
hitting both sides of the spectrum so
yeah I would like to I would like to see
rusted lands back to that was always
that always had some good mix to it -
good mix to it and then we saw a little
bit of the new map the UM yeah it kind
of looks like like dreamin City meets
you know some vex infinite forest kind
of thing going on
yeah it's called fragment fragment
fragment yes I had the Lord house
remember either yeah it was it was just
really good to see that I'm I am they
still kind of coy well that mission City
recording they did tell us a lot of how
the PDP rotations in a go and then a lot
of the elimination stuff you know say
we've seen crucible a stuff we're gonna
get a chance to yeah we're good
I guess they're like four types of
elimination they'll probably be rotating
it through and my guess like we've got
ten weeks I'll probably rotate different
maps on different types and really
trying to get a feel for each of them
but yeah it's just sitting up there see
got crucible and literally says you used
to like this one didn't you I've been
making some adjustments help me get this
ready for the new recruits lord shaxx
fight for valor by eliminating all
opponents this mode is experimental
revive mechanics and heavy ammo rules
will change throughout the season so
that's the big tweaks is heavy and
reminding you get my trousers very need
to be let's go and then Oh last thing we
got to talk about it we don't really
said a lot about is a vex offensive oh
it's like I've got a whole season so
I'll get into that one but okay yeah no
I mean the vex offensive is what what
basically starts this whole arc that
we're talking about mm-hmm so what do
you what are you getting to feel if
we've got these like portals and vex
coming down on the moon and you've got
leafy vex what it would leave you vex
the attack again technolo codes yeah I
love those
so like what's my processors coin and
updated yeah just I mean what do you
think of like what do you think vets
effects offensive as because the Vidak
itself starts mmm-hmm and this is like
one of my screenshots i sat there when I
was going through my little
frame-by-frame the my doc starts with a
what looks to be a taking area because
you have like the taking vex like keys
the box key in a shield and you have
those with little lasers but or the
walls are all taken blights mmm and I'm
like okay hold on why are those in the
same room yeah he's with why you're
taking blights that look like curse of
curse of the dreaming city week three
were than the giant floating balls but
they're like everywhere again and the
VEX offensive I'm like I thought we were
done with the taken yeah I'm so tired of
saying yeah oh yeah splits all the
splits Robbie crazy
oh I'm looking at the captain he's here
here here here here here I was like you
just teleported like six times man now
is it your cooldown it get a kick on at
some point you don't really piss me off
- when you got that little taken in the
back powering up his man and you got it
find out where yet because oh the Goblin
oh god man taking goblins will just piss
you off cuz they oh they're always like
well yeah the guy who's trying to kill
me right now is in full of you but he's
immune because the other guys behind him
doing oh that is like hell that is hell
in the ogre room in shadow drone that is
absolute hell so yeah I mean this is
this is interesting man the Bob Bob game
is just like the fact that literally the
day of the raid it kicks off so it
almost feels to be like they pissed we
did something there they pissed off they
not about any of this thing and they are
sending the entire squadron out here
like the VEX are not playing they
pulling up wherever you add a dropping
through like a vengeance end game on
your left they are here on your left I'm
sorry or your left right center front
back there
right yeah they got tired of us bring in
the first with us we're vex in snow
we're coming in things that's what it
feel like of height man to see what the
mechanic is if it's a horde mode if it's
um
escalation protocol thing so that's that
and then don't forget nothing we got to
talk about to his arm we didn't talk
about the expansion of the forge
mechanic it's turned what is it the new
hive thing that's kind of like an
expansion of menagerie where we're gonna
get to craft weapons yes in a way we
wish it was so a ruin table which he
also home changed he mentioned that in
one of the directors cuts and I'm like
that's a thing it's not a thing that's
been there before and sure enough he's
like well yeah if you don't like what
you got go to the room table craft it
again and keep working like your role so
yeah so vex offensive we've got the six
player match made activity similar to
probably menagerie with mechanics and
it's in the black garden so it'll look
really cool we've got certain things
that come from there as they state the
base armor set that you get for this
season you can get it from the artifact
you want the good rules you're going in
there so you know depending I don't know
if there's difficulties to that thing
yeah if there's like higher stat rules
that come from there if it's like
time-based is it boss pace is it just
luck
so you got different tiers to know there
we've got the escalation of that when
it's the final offensive that's on the
19th and if you go from the nineteen
eight well if you go from the 19th to
the tenth you're also looking at like
the last three weeks of the season of
this offensive right but that's like the
main it for the end of the season well
you got three weeks of not much else out
there maybe some iron banner in between
mm-hmm but that might not request
wrinkle game yeah that final bush we
also had a switch of exotic what's goes
catch I didn't even notice that - you
should - I saw your tweet oh yeah well
they showed that I'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa that's not the same and then
literally I wait some bungie.net and I
was like and they changed the graphic -
yeah break break it down for the PTO's I
mean on October 29th we have multiple
things launching on the calendar
it used to say that it was first of all
lost dungeon momentum control which I
still don't know what it is and the
exotic quest divinity now everybody
thought divinity was related to the raid
it's the linear no it's the tracer I
feel that like makes the crit spot-on
mm-hmm enemies stuff like that that's
not on the calendar anymore what is on
there we have a name for machine-gun
zero parentheses all that thing is now
called Zeno phase mmm-hmm and it is your
exotic machine gun that people say fires
like a linear fusion rifle as low as
hell like what did I say was a 120 or
1/5
know slow slow slow but yeah that's the
new exotic quest divinity off the page
yeah that was yeah I mean it's kind of
weird and and and the way they I guess
we made it more weird is the way they
kind of stealth finesse that like they
do they're just lace that right over the
top they know people have seen it
yeah I mean exactly just weird no like
I'm wondering if they were just using
that as a filler cuz they didn't have a
name for the gun yet nah fam Bungie is
very particular about what they show so
the vibe I got they were ready to show
they gave it they told us that name
right you know divinity we like so that
is just straight to switch that exotic
quest completely no context no reason no
mention you see nothing here this is
this is what we had all along you go on
a date about yeah and if it wasn't for
guys like you to have the old stuff you
know oh yeah we wouldn't know well I
mean people had gone in at PAX and
they're like oh this is in the raid
collection divinities there so then
people like okay the raid quest drops
here right in the raid challenge
launches the next week but now though
everybody's wondering is this part of
the dungeon as a posting in the raid is
this the dungeon exotic that launches on
the same day because
you actually tie in just the way what is
that
bow that I'm blanking on now that asks
will wish and wish endure yeah so that
one came from shattered throne something
similar I think these are not the droids
you're looking for
I love that shaggy so yeah you've got
just like a big shift I've either either
timing or they knew it at some point
they're like hey this exotic maybe both
still launched in the same day but now
we just don't know where divinity comes
from it'll be a less public I really
don't know so but that was an
interesting switch we do have a name
though sound schools Ino page and
somebody looked it up it's related to
bugs anyway so it makes sense like it's
a fitting name they always do well
there's one frame to when I was going
through into somebody's like in the
background working on armor and their
computer and down you can see a book and
you only see a corner of it it says like
em ORS and it looks like an old historic
armor book for like a history book
showing like designs of like you know
old Hall Brits and axes up in one corner
in the shape of helmets and stuff I'm
like all this I mean Bundy is really
good if you ever go digging in and
things like that for like Greek
mythology or Roman gods or so many
different places where they pull me for
that stuff there's usually some place
that comes from or some twist on it or a
variant that always makes it just a
little bit more interesting yeah they
always do a great job and just
everything about the weapons sound
design aesthetic lore you know just they
just do a tremendous job here it was
just funny when they had that one part
where they were going through the season
eight calendar it's like scrolling
across the bottom I had to be like whoa
exactly zero fades on the 29th I was
like so I was like wait what happened
because I solved that first before I saw
the little picture I was like wait did
the name of divinity change do you
change yeah or this Ridge it's very
strange they've made this internal
decision but interesting but yeah that's
one like after that when they talk about
season eight season nine and all that
stuff and I was just like what what what
what hold on what's happening so no it
looks oh yeah and then I've got a sick
picture of that night - yeah he's
literally like it's like he got molten
so I poured over him oh cool he's still
like kind of magma underneath big badass
or man huge bro yeah like he'd to scale
it up bossy he's gonna be a problem
yeah and then we got a few more teases
about the nightmare hunts because we
keep seeing this red fogginess to a
couple places and we see a new nightmare
hunt guy it is the final baron yeah and
I was wondering cuz earlier in the
viaduct they're showing scream crawling
through and I was like those are not
shadowed but the scream crawling through
the tunnel I'm like that's the moon
tunnel I know exactly where they do
exactly as it why the hell are screaming
there why screaming myth yeah so now I'm
wondering okay so do we is one of the
nightmare hunts against scorn cuz I kept
wondering why are scouring on the moon
that's a good point yeah there's a big
systematically right they should just
only be narrative Lee they should only
be from the tangu show you know whatever
so yeah sounds like this is more than
I'm like so it is truly anything in our
past for one it looks like the mayor on
skin vibe can be who knows what our
Warrick's I do missiles y'all we have
the shade of Oryx you got a little bit
baby version you're not gonna have
you're not gonna have the big Aidid that
ascended Oryx so go play go Grady was go
play me one like glad when he played all
a rate or alt in raids together Oh glad
he did alt in raids straight wow a tower
recording it's a bonus channel that is
yeah you want nobody in astrology you
can go watch them all and they'll start
with your favorite one so you don't even
have to watch that much of it just the
first like 45 minutes and you out bad I
got a watch kit for I got a watch wrath
those are those - I do miss wrath Anubis
Raptors fun
shout out to more Lagoon Dona and Eris
by the way mm-hmm you're all
insufferable like that lion that she
says and there's a lot of memes to that
by the way now so many memes that you're
all insufferable but
there's just even a cinematic where you
see her and your guardian standing there
my quarters actually behind you and one
of them yes but there's one of those
little nightmare things floating in the
back just chillin I'm like what the hell
are those it almost feels go like maybe
I'm wrong but it almost feels like she
could see them and maybe go out like it
if you look at a Cora's face she got
that face like girl what are you talking
about
like she just got this weird face like
it's just a concern and like what's
going on and then she looks at you is
your garden as you move forward almost
like you can see it I don't know just
say it's a very interesting scene with
it to be divided this what I got again I
could be completely wrong
Lord guys it's all guessing right now
guess where it almost felt like she's
bugging out like she's having
conniptions and she's you know say and
occur is like Oh see what's going on
here and then maybe it feels like the
Guardian and her can see it but again
could be wrong maybe that Cora does see
that the nightmares and she just all
freaked out too but it's a very
interesting yeah very interesting scene
yeah she's not thrilled about everything
going on mm-hmm
the others all standing loves what catch
me one second talking about me and what
yes I'm ready I'm sorry about hype
didn't fight this one I know the
narrative stuff have you read that the
narrative chapters yeah I read them all
I read all the ones I've had so far if
you look at the game plan up the
thumbnail sir that's next
okay everybody show do what you do I'm
height man you know oh you have a run of
show where like Ivan we're going through
we got pieces to cover let's do it let's
do it but anyway for the night I was
like for the nightmare hunts there's the
one little place where it says even you
know the nightmares or whatever and
there's one I the screenshot shows
nightmare of lor lor inves council hand
and it's showin like the nightmare and
then it like flips and they turn into
fallen mmm so it literally showing them
like a second later and they look like
fallen vandal like mmm
type of stuff and they just literally
turn right in front of you mmm and it
says a powerful nightmare has risen so I
don't know if like the like nightmare
floaty Guardians are gonna be just
always around and sometimes they can
just like flip if it's part of the
nightmare but if they literally turn in
front of them mm-hmm which is crazy for
other nightmares we know we've got crota
we've got school us we've got Gaul we've
got on the goal you know that's gonna be
live we've got another old notify us
yeah that was cool like all the little
of the Moon Astra shaman type stuff the
weapons have what those little like kind
of tokens can a little like almost like
a necklace pendant type thing
yeah that's around them and they have
he's like yeah they have a transparency
issue to them and when the nightmares
are near they like glow bright yeah
that's fine I love the design I love
that those weapons look really cool
there's a lot of detail in those weapons
for our mm-hmm oh by the way another
finisher tidbit here a healthy finisher
finishers he finishers heal you requires
1/10 of your super mm-hmm it's not much
not much umph in there but just get a
quick heal it's worth one not a big cost
but it's there
mmm I've got a good screenshot again we
know the finisher kick can't wait yeah
yeah well yeah we've got so here's a
picture nightmare of phogoth the untamed
but this is at the altars of sorrow now
this is the other thing we got the
screenshot of which is like your
escalation protocol or you're blind well
it's got the little diamonds that look
like they're filling up as you go
through the levels and the waves and
stuff like that so it's gonna be this
looks more outside it looks look saying
either the shadow keep but you're
sitting here fighting a nightmare [ __ ]
off outdoors but also looks like you see
phogoth later on indoors I don't know
where all these people are gonna pop up
they're all over the place like you got
those like mm-hm
so mostly Martina so if you had full
super it
it takes it away it'll take away a tenth
so just lower your bar a bit and you can
charge that back up yeah so that'd be my
guess
now that'd be funny if you had if it's a
tenth and if it's small enough if you
had Geo mags on you run BAM he'll just
keep running cool I'm back heel boom
okay keep going
that's it topping off chaos reach no not
chaos reach yeah so long ago phone so
you've got altars of sorry which
definitely looks like we've got a new
escalation event on the moon which
everybody enjoys those throws really
cool mmm so that seems like a cool
addition that we haven't really seen
yeah and then we get to yeah the rune
table mmm so I've got a screenshot of
the name but I'm scrolling through so
many but what do you think you're gonna
be able to actually I do actually have a
screenshot so I finally got a screenshot
of one of the fourth column mods on the
artefact mm-hmm hey let me see if I can
read it it's half blurry but I'll do my
best
so ballistic combo it is Tier four it's
three energy costs and it's an ax chest
armor mod grants melee energy on final
blows with shield piercing weapons or
when a member of your fireteam shuts
down a barrier champions ability these
champion peoples are gonna be doing some
interesting [ __ ] baby will be doing a
lot of work man
yeah so that's that was just like I
squeezed the screenshot out so I got
that one
mmm that one was cool so but yeah like
the room table is I can't quite figure
out I know there's like a couple
different pieces to like materials we're
good because there's like these phantasm
things and stuff like that that we see
but what do you think like how how deep
do you think the room tables gonna go
are you expecting chalice do you think
they took it too far with chalice what
do you think room table is gonna offer I
mean you kind of have to use chalice as
a base level because you know community
really really dug that you know if
they'll give you more than that
no no I mean I'm what I meant to say is
I don't think you can go to less than
that
but I don't know this one thing about
chance I'm gonna say it's very
controversial I don't know if they
really like that level of customization
only for the stand point it's like you
were really getting down and dirty with
master work and you know I'm saying that
final rule like really driving where the
mass work should be kind of thing so I
don't know I mean I think my gut is
telling me that we will definitely have
at minimum you know some levels of the
child's I don't know like maybe like a
two tiered chalice full kind of thing as
opposed to the last one I think they may
want to keep some level of randomization
yeah it'll be interested say in Nevada
he did say if you're struggling to get
what you want or whatever whatever that
this is gonna be the source to kind of
do it so you know who knows what do you
think hmm I mean so I finally got a
picture so it's bound with blood the
lectern of enchantment mechanism of the
occult built buyers more into harness
even the most unstable of Magic's access
the electron to create gear using
nightmare essences and collect bounties
so you got some bet nightmare bounties
and you've got a couple things you've
got phantasmal fragment which you're
gonna get from fighting the nightmares
there's a little thing next to it which
i think is also in the season pass it's
this little black goldish rock thing and
then you've got one more piece and
you've got daily bound he's like defeat
nightmare hunts defeat enemies in
nightmare hunts with arc damage now I
know we're only getting two strikes but
I also feel like the nightmare hunts are
gonna be like mini strikes - yeah I
think so I think that I think those are
actually gonna be a nice addition of
something else to be like not a strike
with a full boss and in the strike
playlist but just more stuff to do and
especially if we're getting a chance to
grind for stuff should be cool I I don't
know on how far they take it because if
I can sit there and go yeah and if you
do want to farm something between now
and like shadow keep launched between
three rewards for
rewards are however many you get like go
do a menagerie now you're like wait I
mean does it truly just like pop for
hand cannons like one tomorrow I'm in it
I got four Imperial decrees and I
finally got my trench barrel big giant
you know say I mean it's not idea I
would are there like are there extra
Chester's that you open one and just
little bro you Oh bumper it's literary
Christmas in the a.m. and if you're
Foley gold you know you're going to a
postmaster late so I did that an
Austrian I did all stringer now I'm
working on probably like I want to get a
better fixed
what is it fixed I have some things
named under the heavy the hell yeah
thoughts yeah I think yeah I want to get
that I need a better one house cuz -
trash - trash it get in Menagerie all
especially I'm telling you right now you
want that Imperial decree it's one of
the few shot ease that can roll trench
barrel in the kinetic spot so that's
literally escalation protocol shotgun in
the kinetic go get it and it's lit in
the crucible - cuz I might have body in
people with good distance shadows in
pretty great love it no yeah I think
menagerie right now I'll be nice do you
what do you feel when they take that
away from you though he's gonna I'm up
feeling away only because I like
menagerie for different reasons yo shut
up de calais me your calves me having me
die laughing in a like the stuff he'd be
saying do you really just listen to cows
oh he's he's ridiculous
he's ridiculous he's ridiculous like the
stuff that comes out of his mouth
absolutely funny so um yeah um yeah I am
gonna miss it I'm gonna miss it but I
mean if we formed everything we can
possibly form and then how it is how
much legs is it really gonna have
especially after you get you after I get
my um my catalyst is really not gonna be
any reason for me to go back in there
you know so yeah hmm I don't know I mean
just for people who might be willing to
do it later or still didn't get their
roles and stuff like that you what do
you think it should be let what do you
think the final number should be because
we're gonna get this thing up to like
five for that last few days I think what
do you think the final number I mean one
five three two where's that where's the
final like all right stay there so
beyond surprise should be it probably
should be two or three tops because it's
kind of disgusting right now
well let me right now is probably broken
but it like to be like I like the two
with a Chance of three or - yeah so -
with the juice of three of the gauchos
yep hey could you go in there you like
alright if you got one it was bad roll
as like I got a second shot let me see
what I go right as my own attorney see
what you know - is a nice I think fair
that's fair enough because she still
makes you go back in there if you want
specific stuff yeah if you want to go
grind something else now it's not so bad
either reckonings no more bad modifiers
yeah but you know what's funny I was
doing reckoning before I hate a little
spare rations I got my own like the
snipers is late
oh I checked because I was listening to
like DCP talked about it last night and
they've gone through their roles I have
a Soul Survivor with firing line and
fourth time's the charm
whoa whoa that's serious that series so
yeah rapidly landing precision it's will
return two rounds of the magazine and
this weapon deals increased precision
damage with near two or more allies only
rate sniper yeah that's right it's right
ready I looked and I was like and they
were like oh do you have this one and I
looked that's just gotta be one of the
decent rules to get I got it with light
mag so I didn't get extended and I've
got it wouldn't corkscrew rifling so
just pretty much mines like stable I
don't have like the range on it but it's
definitely stable so I was I was
decently happy to check because I
thought at one point I saw that drop way
to flex on us to be flexible dork and
goggles over there I go for I'm flexing
hard with that that bro things I'm know
what that is disgusting kill hell
you got your kill clip rampage
with the hand cannon buff that's a hard
kill I love coming to hand cannons
there's not OPV e-baby PvE oh yeah
nobody damage bro it's gonna be
disgusting Edie I'm getting bonus damn I
already got my loadout there's gonna be
Kendall for the void I'm gonna rock void
I'm gonna rock the only thing happening
two hand cannons as range that's gonna
get affected the PvE minor damage is
getting balanced out but the minor
damage is getting balanced out by the
precision drop didn't they get a
percentage while I'm not thinking they
got up no no no damage buff damages
against the minor enemies and that only
gets equated by the precision takedown
that they're fixing your brung it's not
it's late it punches less it literally
punches less that's what it was no but
anyway animation range fall-off hitting
harder and then just the minors
everything got a minor because they
taken away the precision so that's all
nobody a Bungie let's above hand cannons
yeah nobody says that no Avadi yeah I'm
ready man I'm still ready I got a sick
land if I can outwait a loadout for a
shadow keep that I can't wait to test
out yeah we got rune table we got
nightmare hunts we got a dungeon we got
a raid we got a new exotic we have an
exotic floating in the wind
mhm we got the vex invasion and all
those little things are coming are you
gonna be bored in this in this $35
expansion that I don't know they're
giving away the annual pass for Forsaken
owners by the way that was a legit move
yeah that was legit that was a joke that
was I saw the patch notes and I was like
I literally it's like doing a
double-take be like oh yeah take away
modifiers and reckoning oh yeah feeling
forsaken you have the and you passed
content wouldn't like that was I didn't
expect it it's a good thing like that so
I guess now if you just if you forsaken
pretty much just has it all if you get a
hold of forsaken somehow you have all of
forsaken like you have all of your two
there's no don't have Daniel pass to
heaven and you'll pass the only thing I
think they need to clarify at this point
is if you have if you're like new light
and you buy shadow keep do you still
have to go buy forsaken which i think is
yes but then the question is as they're
doing the season pass cross save I
really would like I really would like
them to do for second cross save hmm cuz
like if you buy the license somewhere
you buy it once I don't want like I mean
for you for the rare you know honorable
man who goes between PC and Xbox hey you
are better than I will be I am NOT going
I'm I was so so bad I would be so bad
it's good like if you play on PC and
then you're like you got to go PI you
gotta go buy it again over there yeah
it's like my question it'd be nice if
like maybe just the newest thing
requires the purchase and then you know
after you get like - you know the next
year then forsaken care then it's just
like it's in there just like new light
so that's what I want to know because
it's like if I I'm gonna have shadow
keep right you have all that stuff and
if you go over to you know console
whatever you know does that does that
carry over are you acted to buy that
thing on the other platform so they've
got to be a little more clear with how
that's gonna work Benedict yes or no I
mean I guess most if you're gonna go
help somebody with the new raid you're
gonna buy shadow keep on that other
platform but if you're gonna go grind
out you know oh I gotta go work on some
powerful engrams and we go back to the
Dreaming city hit up cheddar throne I'm
not gonna do that on next spot it's
probably not worth you buying it on Xbox
again if you can go grind that stuff on
PC but it also just seems a little it
just would be nice but again I know
they're still trying to make what they
can off at least still it'd be a pretty
solid product that's not even that
expensive honestly mmm yeah we've still
got it we still got some cool matrix
yeah it's like so plan on moved to PC
for forsaken but forsaken isn't on
steam yet so I don't know which I will
keep to purchase PC or ps4 mm-hmm so if
you so cryptic do you have like
forsaking the Annual Pass on ps4 at this
point because if you do and you do cross
SAV crap where does that go
should you buy it on ps4 as your main
but then just play it on PC probably so
you have the annual pass you have
everything on there my bet would
probably be buy it on ps4 and then just
cross save you'll just turn around and
play wait
see that's day that's the question
that's the thing is like you're forsaken
is like if you if you log on on PC is
that stuff not gonna be there because I
know the battlenet system they're
talking about the Forsaken transition is
gonna be like delayed on that day like
that is just gonna be like you know some
databases working through it's a list of
crazy amount of stuff to do yeah and
it's got to get through it so basically
the long and short of it with that is
please if you're halfway through the
Forsaken campaign get it done yeah cuz
if you don't dare you setting you back
to the beginning as if you didn't do it
yep so you got to get that yeah but yeah
that's the big one it's like if you buy
shadow keep the $35 you get season of
undying with it if you get the deluxe
you get the following seasons those are
true separate though so you don't if you
buy shadow keep season of undying that's
included so you'll get to experience all
of this season but you would have to
give a season pass after deluxe is 25
more for the other three seasons and
then the previous stuff that's the weird
thing
yeah if you plan to move to PC but
forsaken isn't on Steam
you might honestly just wait you can
pre-order shadow keep see what happens
and then if forsaken is sitting on Steam
it's probably gonna be pretty cheap
right after shadow key comes out I don't
imagine four seconds more than it's $25
now for the whole thing
it might even stay at 25 or maybe go to
20 it's probably not gonna be expensive
as the big one I think so I might wait
just till October first and if you need
to tick off that license just wait and
do it on Steam if you need to yes
problem
my bad agreed agreed but yeah we also
got a nice sneaky article thanks to I
think I saw it in one video and I was
like how are people seeing more than
just the page we saw then I had to go
hunt on the website then I made it a
picture that picture was used in an
article so shout out say it with your
chest
hey shout out to Paul Tassie by the way
awesome awesome guest on here but I just
literally took all ten sections of the
annual pass put them together in just a
picture kids so you can see the the free
verse the other one as you go through
the ranks and it's sitting in a Forbes
article so forever and somewhere out
there the way the shoutout now with the
shout out but forever there could be
many whoops any bonds hiss on the same
screen
and I was like that'll never happen
again but I'll take it make baby made it
that's what I'm talking about let's go
so let's talk about these seasoned ranks
mm-hm
I want your thoughts as we go through
hold on let me clear my throat
let me clear my throat clear my throat
yeah man season ranks buddy yeah so we
got your graphic there it's a long
graphic I'm just looking at the Bungie
page at this point so we go through one
through ten and just go each page
yep three of the top seasonal at the
bottom so a lot of people in asking
about these like cubes that have little
orange pegs sticking out so my
assumption because that is something
that was also at the gunsmith when they
were pulling the of Soulstice armor from
him those were also sitting there and I
think those are gonna be the free
infusion things okay because Luke Smith
said hey people in new light and also on
the free path we're gonna give them
these like free upgrade modules think of
it as free infusion and when you say
module that looks like a module things
like a whole bunch of crap stuck
together right so that looks like the
upgrade module so it's like free
infusion I that's gotta be what that is
because nothing else word wise matches
that so I think that's what those are
gonna be seasonal rank one of the free
path is your dump of everything
get your armor sets you get your exotic
hand cannon we've already talked about
that one it's fine so that's there now
as we go through you'll see people gets
on kit I think this is mostly like a
hunter as they went through for the
pictures yeah it looks like you're
getting armor sets in different places
we have what looks to be maybe a
transmat effect at rank up 6 we've got
some legendary shards we've got some
enhancement cores and we've gotten the
kickee emote or the kickee finishing
move that's a 10 yeah that one's mine
can't wait for that then we go 11 to 20
we've got one of these this is where we
get to stuff that people have been
asking questions about even though I've
got them all over the place so on the
seasonal path there are these look to be
I don't know if they're bounties mm-hmm
like okay look at 11:16 20 they have
different icons behind them one will
have a sword want to look exactly the
same and have a shield the one on the
right looks like it's got three purple I
don't I don't haven't what I don't know
what all those are if they're bounties
that's kind of cool give you something
to go do what else do you think they
could because I'm not sure they're
bounties but I don't know what they
would be yeah that is definitely
something specific to the day I've got
no idea like zero like again a lot of
this you know a lot of the icons you'd a
lot the only thing that looks somewhat
familiar to anything that the thing that
look like a strange coin everything go
yeah we got a leaf we got a leafy
strange coin you know we got the scepter
dig it when I scrap it like we can see
picture ID to put it on it's great hey
we work on that we had s oh yeah I'll
change up that'd be that'd be a the
scene transition then I got to move our
faces and you get the web on the side
let me work on that I'll get that but
yeah like twelve you've got like the
leafy the like black garden coin which I
don't know what those are gonna be
related to the vet like the season pass
vendor maybe yeah that's a guess some
modules some armor you get your free
cosmetic engrams couple Legendary's
level 18 looks to actually be what I was
talking about for that
kind of glowing the rock type thing
mm-hmm even though behind it that looks
like doesn't it look like a ship behind
it yeah it kind of does so is that like
a ship material I don't know no that
looks like a ship behind it I never
noticed that before but dude I don't
know what that would be then like every
9 level at the night at the 9 of every
level looks like you just have a box of
crap yeah you have like a teal triangle
outside but everything in there looks
like they just dumped crap in the box is
it just gonna be like random like
planetary materials because it looks
almost like planetary materials and
stuff on a cup like the little piece
sticking out so maybe it's just a box of
materials who knows well 25 our first
exotic engrams talked about it hold on
we gotta get higher up this is where
everybody's gonna get old get their
panties in a twist so 25 you get your
first exotic on the season path right so
one cool and it is truly an exotic
engrams because they rolled over one of
those in the video it's an anagram it
could be an old pair of boots it could
be a pair of lion rabbits yeah you go to
spin 25 oh I got a pair I came back on a
pair of lion rampant boots add the rules
not that great well that's trash mm-hmm
so that's season ranked 25 out the
window don't even need it mm-hmm so
level 35 we do for the free tract have
the hand cannon for the free and people
are definitely saying about 35 is where
free trick gets quiet yeah very quiet
little tumbleweed there's not much out
there season track so you got another
one of those coins a couple Enhancement
cores here and there a couple of these
random possibly bounties I still don't
know what the hell they are another box
of crap mm-hmm uh you get 245 you get
the machine gun from the season so you
get a weapon nothing from 41 to 50
really get shader hunter cloak boots
nothing now everybody
gonna start freaking out at about 60
yeah 60 everyone and their other
brothers mother gets an exotic even yeah
the free path because that's where it's
at a free path exotic what do you think
sir yeah tell me what you think do you
think when you get to level 60 this will
be this will be a big deal it's probably
I mean it's one of them things that
either they probably been grinding you
know give me something yes like there's
its heart exotics of random like my
brother or some people tell me that like
exotics are even harder to come by now
if you have a linear path will be like
hey only got like two more levels and
maybe like play some more strikes
tonight maybe I can get this thing and
then you get an exotic it is a linear
path to get something and but it's an
Engram you never know what its gonna be
these are not like here's the new
exotics at level 30 40 and 50 it's like
here's an Engram there's a lot of old
stuff and if you picture the free path
there's so much stuff that those people
are not gonna have mmm-hmm so that's
alright so I don't care about the
exotics in this until we get to the end
we'll talk about that do you care up to
now do you care up to now I kept it now
for another track but we'll get to that
okay what's on the bottom track that
pisses you off the prism I'm not feeling
the premium track I'm gonna be honest
like the premium track specifically
exotics huh they out here raining exotic
now here rainy I said up till now I'm at
level 60 I'm not there yet up to 60 put
a pin in that
before almost thing alright okay now
we're at 65 that's how long you had to
wait that's all over that so 65 your
your previous one was at 25 for the
premium track mmm-hmm so so 65 you got
an exotic you got ornaments you've got
another set of prism another box of
stuff like one two three four of these
because one looks like crucible one
looks like story another one later
definitely has a gambit symbol behind I
don't
yeah I don't know what they are they
like little baby buffs are they are they
bounty I don't I don't know it's so
weird
mm-hmm oh yeah 65 you get an exotic mmm
so that'll be your third so far how many
do I need to say did I say we're gonna
be in this whole thing remember how many
I said I forgot you said four how many
are in the premium Trek four that's nice
don't mean I gotta like it but it is
this is where people actually will start
to have a contentious point and I'm
gonna let you open up don't worry
so it's 65 we've gotten exotic mm-hm
seven to four we've got an exotic and
then 98 we've gotten exotic so where are
the exotics weighted towards the end
towards the end where are people gonna
potentially not reach on the season pass
if they're a mid to casual player
they're not gonna make it to the end
what are they gonna give you those last
couple weeks what are they gonna give
you in the last couple weeks as a way to
finish the season pass a way to buy your
levels what are you buying now you can
go because I know this is all you've
been waitin to mechanically introduce
hey I've been played so guess what I'm
gonna tune in at the end and I'm gonna
buy technically a bunch of exotics that
would be on that pack I'll be right
there listen this is my thing it's
exotics in my opinion we're in a great
pocket come forsaken come forsaken they
became rare it took me a while I didn't
get Geo mags for a while and you know
what I wasn't I was disappointed in when
other people had it but I was I was
actually feeling good that is taking a
while shout out to the sirens that's
going on but huh
anyway like I was saying it's just one
of those things that I love that feeling
of playing and you genuinely feel
surprised when you get an exotic you
generally feel like you've played and
there's a lot of work I mean almost any
work they went
orangy but you feel good some people
great some people don't and this is this
is the counterpoint to that some people
can go through and have exotic strop and
they just have really good luck oh I got
my Geo mags you're like all right I got
my fourths vigilance wing I'm good I
don't need those anymore
so if you know if you're like hey I can
grind out two more levels tonight I give
it a chance at something it leaves me a
chance I've already grinded 60 levels to
get here
how many weeks of czar do you think
you're gonna go through in 60 levels
before you even get to that second one
I'm at to answer the question
listen man you talk in orangey we cannot
decipher that that's just RNG we don't
know I'm just saying like how long do
you think it's gonna take you to get
through about 60 levels how long it's
gonna take me to get to 60 levels it's
like ranked 60 in the season pass yeah
cuz they said it was like maybe an hour
or rank so you go 60 hours okay okay how
where do you put 60 hours over weeks for
you how much do you get to play I mean
it's all it's all random but it's all
dependent on investment by again I'm not
gonna everyone's not gonna play a
specific amount of time but I understand
so okay I guess the point is mine is
like say if you do 10 hours a week
that's six weeks you've seen deserve
five times you got five faded engrams in
that same time okay you also get
searched showing up with four exotics
and some new some old some helpful some
trash some decent really some are gonna
be crap we're gonna be looking at sir
for stat roles now more than any right
forearm right so he's gonna come through
with 24 exotic chances that you can buy
and this is saying six weeks this is
just a rough average of somebody who
plays ten hours a week some will be
crazy and finished this a week one who
knows yeah well if they play do you
still think they're not gonna have like
three or four exotics drop anyway no in
enough hours to get there oh no you you
just cut out that you cut out that
entire sentence all right you keep Josh
Fitness I'm not letting you here's
since forsaken and I see you talking
about mostly Martinez I'm in the hot
seat I'm getting out of this hot seat
right now Saint let me finish here's the
deal since forsaking the drop rates went
down they went down on this battle
pastor thing is increasing drop rate
they're literally giving you exotics and
then we're forgetting the big thing that
we won't let me finish which is the
exotic protection day and they enabled
that they look at what you don't have
and they're giving it to you what I
hated about pre forsaken was do we were
getting all the exotics so fast we were
getting everything then it takes the fun
out of the game you're like oh I got
everything ok cool what's next to do you
know I'm saying you've got everything
besides us something a quest driven
exotic I just feel a way about it like
they all here handing them out like
candy like I don't like that for that
remember the people who didn't like d2
at the beginning this is what they can
place what we complain yo I got
everything the exotics feel real then we
do it you know it was in a good spot now
we be doing this it's like I don't know
I'm just I just feel the premium track
is it's a lot it's look at this what
love was with look at you scream it you
know what is that level lose that 25
your numbers I got a bad image so it's a
little but the reality it just receives
that you know it's one get one at 25 one
at 25 next one is 60 mm-hmm yeah when
you get to the end of your season pass
yeah you do get more but twenty five and
sixty you have to guaranteed within that
time range I mean 60 levels is gonna be
a stretch and what most people in chat
are saying how many people get an exotic
that is a duplicate that doesn't matter
that is gonna be he's like yeah but
there's no protection you keep saying
there's protection you keep saying the
drop rates have changed I get a decent
met exotics and they're all crap I get a
decent man diffic dingo but you've got
everything but I still get a decent
amount of them but your investment is
way
higher than the average but in your
blazing we're blazing if the average
person if you play a lot like I mean if
you if you play I would say what we're
gonna say the average per me 10 hours I
don't know what the app is still Pro
even sounds like a lot that's even
sounds like a lot okay so if you're
saying not even 10 hours then they're
not gonna finish this thing okay then
they're really not gonna get handed this
stuff and then especially so like Ben
you're talking about like them getting
it handed to him if the average person
plays 8 hours a week you take 8 hours a
week and that's 8 ranks eight weeks of
64 hours they're only at rank 64 even on
the normal and they have two weeks to go
and that might be when they get to start
buying it right and then you could buy
it then I can buy it but they've been
playing for eight weeks at the normal
drop rates eight weeks mm-hmm how like
and then it's like oh you want to please
you over eight weeks they can't get
exotics you discipline I'm just saying
in eight weeks if you're saying eight
hours a week can you give it an average
of an hour a rank and you go eight weeks
eight hours a week you're looking at
near the end of the season and they have
had two exotics that came from this
they've seen desert come through eight
times they're getting it drops trouble
but they're also gonna get drops
throughout the world they're gonna get
some exotics while they play right it is
now it is why why do we lead a
supplemental thing with more exotic size
just what I feel I I just no no let me
ask you this let me ask you this say you
had been going through eight weeks mmm
you've been going through you got like
you know maybe an exotic a week for just
playtime or a little bit from tzer's or
hasn't came it's been eight weeks he
hasn't come in and you get this exotic
drop am 64 let me play for one more hour
then you're geo mags drop okay so you've
been waiting on these for eight weeks
your entire season waiting on this new
exotic you get an exotic Engram
you actually finally get the thing you
want and then you look at the role in
its trash right so how much weight again
this is the this is over okay about the
trash roldy addict only we care about
the trash okay to a point but fine you
still got fine okay so you get
exotic it took you eight weeks to get
there is my point and you fight and you
still got it by orangie because it is
not a guarantee of anything new that
protection is crap by the way mmm
that doesn't work I can tell you because
I got two Jade rabbits I got two Jade
rabbits in the same nightfall I have it
on video because you have everything as
I'm trying to say if you don't have like
a normal person
that doesn't happen you gotta keep your
in this super-high call hardcore bracket
that is not the real world
all right we gotta talk like normal
people okay then help me play the game
destiny the RNG algorithm is going to
give them stuff they don't have that's
just normally now we're throwing extra
premium on all this stuff
and giving them more stuff they can have
all the exact that's all I'm saying it's
just way too many sources then we don't
even know how many exotics are in what
shadow keep what if there's not a lot
again like what was it or Perth or it
was like three per class let's just say
an armor we had the weapons we don't
know how many eggs are if we're going
through the exotic pool so fast I'm a
little concerned
maybe I'm blowing this out of proportion
right it's like when my exotics feel
exotic we don't have to have everything
all the time okay so I so two things Wow
magneto and I talk about what I'm about
to talk about mm-hmm give me a one inch
at if you're with me and it's not a big
deal give me a two or an F in chat if
you're with Cognito but what I want to
say though and that's something you
actually said that is the overall bigger
issue exotics don't feel like that's new
one period they haven't since destiny to
came out we're not going to that we not
going oh they do not feel the same
exotics no exotics a lot of exotic suck
mmm a lot more armor than a weapon
but a lot of exotic armored tends to not
be great oh yes yes I'll give you that
yes yes
weapons have had their waves and we've
got some coming back but like when you
say you want exotics to be valuable you
want them to feel exotic right now
everyone in the game should have them
not everyone should be rolling the whole
thing you are in the S tier of Playmate
of playtime but how many of the I have
them all fine except the rainbow switch
okay you're gonna help me okay that's my
rabbits you not Little Jimmy not to God
it isn't the point I'm getting at this
is the point I'm getting at how many do
you use oh come on come on that's
exactly my point everything is useful it
just comes down to some things yes are
better than others but it's like am I
gonna say because I got I don't know
just are randoms now you know because I
got graviton Lance you know and then I
got I don't know you know under Lord or
whatever like they're all rankings right
but we're not gonna are you doing a
perfect one merciless
right merciless when des d2 first came
out was merciless right then stuff came
out and things got better and then you
got better stuff to and other stuff the
Merciless got here but for the new guy
that don't know about jotoon they don't
have any of that he got murked
lit he's like oh this exotic is amazing
that's what I'm trying to say you're
forgetting about the little guy that's
all I remember that guy
he gonna be happy with his merciless he
gonna be okay is he really gonna be
happy with my merciless isn't even that
great of a spot right now it's good you
don't play with anymore because you're
so st you're so boozy you got the best
of the best you know the role you know
the DPS these guys don't care they like
yo I got a fusion that can shoot deep
here so fast and I got a catalyst they
hot right now that's all I'm saying
it
we're not gonna do this d2 exotics it's
come on bro like shout out to my boy
would you like listen we've got a
Korea's running around we got a lot of
useful stuff the only thing I will give
you I will completely agree armour not
in a good place compared to day one yeah
and you're a lot more armored that
happens I don't even a lot of these
exotic armors and d2 you know in the
bushes like they are just that
improvement stuff for recharge rate
improvement kind of things or they're
very tethered to one subclass I will
give you that I'm saying but that's all
yes he's boozy he is tell you bad this
guy right here where he forgets what it
was but to be broken struggling oh all
my point is and so you're given somebody
who takes new who gets new lights yes
okay mmm-hmm they see somewhere at sixty
they get a guaranteed exotic they're
gonna get some throughout but do you
think them playing through at some point
getting one more they've seen an exotic
drop and they get one by the way
but it's to a point that like for the
way you said you that new person feels
about an exotic if they're playing
through and going rank one to sixty and
they're truly playing it for free but
Roland do an old stuff do an older AIDS
and they get one more exotic in there
that that if anything for them is a is a
path for them to grind for now stack in
the premium with about three at the end
you can have it either here nor there if
you play enough to get there or you like
you know what I can pay some money to
get a couple exotic drops or you can pay
that five ten bucks or whatever it may
be who knows what those rinks are gonna
cost and what if you just get like what
if it's me does that benefit me at all
don't matter for you well okay so how
many people who are gonna get the
premium pass may already have most of it
anyway how many people are gonna really
get the value out of those when they get
to the end because what am I going to be
going for
besides rate exotics mm-hmm with the
people who are going to grind for it
when they get there they're at exist get
they're getting even duplicates of what
they have anyway the person who doesn't
have enough time they might be buying a
couple more of their own oh really but
really like half the half the stuff they
have a chance to get any way would be
armored as it is so it's just again it
just is is it the most egregious thing
I've ever seen no you know is it I'd
shout out to a bluesy one blackjack of
somebody in this chat I think on black
wings I mean look somebody who said like
look they work black wings yeah I'm
gonna put your business out there black
wing but you know the way you said that
yo you don't have time you know as far
as your your real life getting in the
way and stuff like that and I get that
respect you know all I'm saying is you
know this is structured so that that
group can say hey I don't have time it's
getting towards the end of the season
you know what I'll get that premium
joint
I'll give for you know four five exotics
towards the end and you know I'll get
I'll get everything I should see I'll
get everything but you have a chance to
kind of catch up so to speak I just
struggle with this whole catch-up thing
like I just it's like fam that's these
not for everybody this is an investment
right okay so what do you think about
the ascend insurance what do you think
about the Senate for the and against my
loved Azam's I love that because they're
forcing pinnacle activity play to go get
something what I don't like is yo let me
go take out my whoa go BA okay why are
you freaking more about the season pass
when exotics are in an in an encounter
because that's an earned activity why I
got I'm not paying I'm not gonna say one
money tonight phone call this week I
look let me god that's what it would
feel like so if you go to a nightfall
every week you're like commonly
guaranteed in exotic you're okay with
that
that's the game play that's dude the
chance of doing a hard activity to
to earn it exotic okay but I like hey
let me go jump in your backpack let me
go do this whatever every like okay in
eight weeks you're guaranteed an exotic
from the nightfall do you really like if
that's a common thing lady how about
credit card I get my paypal go get it
okay but for like four mmm okay there's
a chance for some to buy but do you not
think then putting that any night
phildee values in exotic already if
you're just like it's gonna be a common
drop in there like exotics are going to
be like you used to like d1 got a chance
mmm-hmm for night falls I mean you got a
chance of it exotic in places this is
sounding like exotic well it's like we
don't know what common means we don't
know what copies you know me so I get
that put shout out to mostly Martinez
window knife or oh my Dark Knight Rises
hello gentlemen yes please ask the
question in the chat we want to know
what's going on um you know listen when
we play d1 and we did the nightfall
remember I remember those times that
that end game screen comes and your man
got the Gjallarhorn and you ain't
getting a like a you got something cool
but it wasn't an exotic so we don't know
how to ask alone play we don't know if
this is guaranteed exotic again the term
common definitely feels you know like
something's different so we got to see
but I rather that then open up my
checkbook and say you know what let's go
now this is big money big money
let's go get some it just feel weird to
be they just feel weird that's all I get
I get the other side I get people who
say look I don't got time you know um
and they're putting it in for these guys
and we just got to see how it plays out
we got to see our plays out we don't
know
in your defense we don't know um exotic
drop rates for shadow keep they don't
know if it retains what forsaken hands
you know we don't know how many exotics
they are but if there's a plethora of
exotics then yeah this may work out a
little better that guys get a shot but
based on what we've seen so far with
each um seasonpass installment it's kind
of been low I would say you know as far
as the amount of exhaust per class and
light couple mm-hmm
one will be like yet yotan that only
dropped in the forges
you had izanagi from the crazy quests
mm-hmm
so I mean everything's been so I mean
shadow keep is the Forsaken chunk is
bigger but I honestly still feel like
this is gonna be the smaller chunk like
I don't see as many exotics as forsaken
and like I said my my only concern is
again the thing I this is where I'm at
the heart of my whole argument to me
destiny is at its best when exotics are
harder to get that's just me I love that
feeling of walking in the tower and
you're like yo what is that where did
you get that
and I'm saying do you want any more do
you actually see anybody anything on
anybody's back and be like yeah yeah
when I didn't have Gio minutes for like
old season oh wait two seasons I didn't
get geo mags to like almost end of
season of drifter before opulence would
start like I didn't get a lot Phoenix
Protocol I didn't get the prime stuff
like I was running around with just
maybe controverse hold as far as the war
locking sighs it was burning me people
tell me how much fun they were having
with geo map it doesn't but again it was
okay it was okay I was like you know
what cool and I was getting other things
I was getting other things again but we
got to see how the drop rates gonna go
we got to see how that stuff now I mean
the biggest thing between us both yeah
we're gonna see how it goes
we'll see what we see what I said about
on December 10th we're talking about the
new season really okay it's out to go
good better otherwise the season ranks
have some controversy to them I will say
99 that sort emote looks pretty cool the
sword larry mount looks cool
Ariana's valuev got a couple ornaments
and stuff in there
over
most of it okay so fight in the season
pass and it's not a lot you really are
excited about are you I mean I just
don't know what stuffy yeah I don't know
what the boundaries are the box of
materials I'm gonna know what Kors do
somebody in chat was saying not sure I
like seeing Kors in there I don't know
how many are you gonna drop
they said it shouldn't be famine or they
said it shouldn't be famine but I'm not
sure we're gonna be feasting either this
year we're not looking at with the
proper context right because we don't
know what half of the stuff we don't
know what's going on the big thing is we
as you're saying it's like we don't know
but also the big thing is this is just
on top of what we've ever had in destiny
before it is just more things to do we
have the artifact which is a new thing
for power grind you know infinite and
that it and break all that stuff you can
get the mods in there we've got armor
2.0 you're gonna be chasing stat builds
now as opposed to did I get the arms
that have the specific role no now I'm
going for stat rolls think about exotics
now what if you have a solar and ARCA
devoid of the same damn thing you might
need three so those exotic to me already
haven't you may want a duplicate so the
like that's where part of the issue that
I have where I do agree with you is
where exotics have lost their kind of
luster and value is because now if you
have armor 2.0 you put your mods in
there what you're looking for is stats
and you're looking for the proper energy
type on armor and I don't know if
they're all gone if the energy type is
gonna roll random or not mm-hmm but it's
like if that's the main purpose like
exotics kind of just fill another hole
they don't do especially armored exotic
armor is kind of rough exotic weapons I
mean they are their own thing they act
differently but mostly the armors I
guess where I have the issue we're
seeing duplicates is going to be like
getting five more exotic engrams they
could all be armor and they could all do
nothing for me and that's the point
where is like to me it's not as a big of
a deal if you see your Geo mags drop and
it's like a full let me see how bad I
can make one say if it's a full mobility
strengthen role as far as possible
and you're needing those boots to be Ark
and they are void so awful stats and
they're void and they don't even pair up
with all your weapons you're using a
good you got your new exotic bow and
you've got it in there and they don't
even help you at all
mmm so then you're just at a point
really like I got it but now I don't
even know if so yeah so there's to me
the more chances you get at some of
these weapons like kind of hating that
checkbox of getting more and more that
list will go quick which has a Down
which has some downfalls I agree with
that but also the other weapons you'd
done but on the other side like now that
we're trying to get after Armour 2.0
mm-hmm the more chances we have it that
five is not good trap five will be a
drop in the bucket I think for trying to
actually really get what you're going
for so it depends like will it
potentially mess up weapons if you get
too many it has a chance to do that but
also when it comes to the armor it's
potentially not even remotely enough so
it's just I could see both I can see
both sides is kind of the idea but also
I think exotics a lot of them anymore I
mean I have my set ones I use if things
are gonna get buffed yeah pull some
stuff out of the vault but there's a lot
of things that might be a weapons or
armor that are just sitting collections
dismantled and I'm like oh yeah I just
mental that a while ago so there's a lot
of exotics that don't matter too much so
I just think that again we gotta be
careful as the hardcore just basically
the way we think I think we just think
different right we look at an exotic
getting we look at having value in
having multiple exotic armors casual Joe
he's like yo I got such as such I'm good
you don't say like he's got like I know
like not my fear is again all this stems
from the d2 vanilla feared and I don't
want us to again not saying this is
completely egregious and this is exactly
like d2 vanilla no I'm just saying parts
of the reasons why we were disgusted
with d2 vanilla was they were giving
things away like candy and then once we
got everything we got this interested
that's my overall premise behind
of this and I and I know how casual
stinks II they're not like us when they
get all their stuff in their Gjallarhorn
or whatever it and then they get all
their cool little armor they're out they
all into the next game like if there's
something to chase you stay you're more
invested that's my point us we're
hardcore we're like yo I got my third
one I got to guard role I got the guard
build I'm in you don't say I'll grind
for that but the casual dude he gonna
leave and that's that's the only thing
I'm worried about that part so we shall
see maybe it is handled in a very
tactful way and it's none of this stuff
maybe the exotic pool is large you know
we'll see we just got to see how it
plays out we want a lot of stuff you
don't know until actually so I guess the
other side of that sorry guys we were on
this one today we just world war
anything we are we into mixes the last
part so the other side of that you
literally talk about a new person coming
in there crying in for a while but they
have something on the horizon that they
can continue to grind for so that gives
a new player who has a collection that
is next to empty a reason to be like
mm-hmm
okay we got some handle cameras up it's
all good
mods do your thing I know what we do
hold that thought
sorry somebody came in and was just
terrible Oh bender you're the man thank
you brother appreciate it
continue nothing stops last word yeah we
out here good sorry oh that's not cool
oh good bro let's get to it man ain't
never gonna stop what we doing here
positivity young soul anything nope
you're all good yep I've caught up with
just about everything in my discord and
twitch that never so anyway so basically
what I was saying is you take a new
purse
who is going through the game they're
like ham like little 35 and they but say
they bought shadow keep waiting by
forsaken they've been crying in through
there at like level 35 you know they're
getting some stuff they're seeing the
armor drops they're like man there's a
lot of exotics out there have not got
that many but out there like 60 I can
start getting some that takes somebody
who may have been playing destiny less
but gives them a reason to play more
right no I who would you say so that's
another sighs I like Bungie keeping
their community eating it longer mm-hmm
I mean yeah it gives somebody who
doesn't have the chance to play it but
somebody who wants to play it gives them
that carrot on the end of the stick of
an exotic especially somebody's trying
to complete a collection or even add two
things for an empty wall because they
have nothing yet it's a chance for them
to get like have that like okay I can at
least know I can get like three or four
more exotics I've no idea how many other
ones that we get but I keep playing I'll
know I'll get there so that's a way for
somebody who's newer to it on the other
side to be like hey this is really
really cool hey if I finish this level
cool if into the straight cool I just
got my new exotic yes what did I get
and that's another side for a moment but
as you said there are a lot of them now
so if you take a new casual player who
doesn't have that much as doesn't have a
complete collection and five total over
the course of the season right is not
all of them so it depends on where
people are at what they're coming from
stuff like that but generally I think
there is I see both sides of where I
don't know to me I just don't see it as
big I understand we don't want to like
swamp them already but I'm but four so
take us for example where we have most
of them right does it it doesn't faze me
either way because if I get some I
figure half are going to be rules I
don't need half we're going to be
duplicates that's fine
those are not gonna be the types of
things that like complete the missing
pieces for me right and for other people
who don't have as much time it gives
them a chance at stuff they may
otherwise not have gotten because lucky
that's the counter-argument yet after
Connelly and then there's people like it
be like yo I've been playing I have I've
been completely unlucky you know I'm
saying you know orangie hasn't blessed
me and you know man at least I know at
level 20 something you know I'm gonna
get something right and I get it you
don't say
flea you know I'm making a big big thing
out of nothing and it's that that nice
little balance that's all I hope it's
just that nice little balance so that
you know those guys get what they want
but ultimately you know I still would I
would just like to drop race to remain
at forsaken love I think that is just
perfect man I just love how long it be
taking sometimes to forget you know the
exotics but I've really really enjoyed
so that we've talked about
oh no black wings talking about that
he's actually kind of okay with the up
you know he's excited about it above you
got mm-hmm gay killer day I don't know
good Jackie I don't know he said they're
exotic some people got their first try
and people other ones people never get
like Yoda in for example yeah so I mean
you can sit there and farm for just
until you're blue in the face if you are
unlucky you don't get that one and
that's right that's truly one that's
stuck in an event that's not that's RNG
within an event that's not a Zirin gram
that's not a world drop that is I can't
go do a rate and have a chance to get
yotan it's like I am only crossing in
one place when that's where some people
get specific the same thing with r8
exotics and those are even harder to get
cuz I gotta go through the whole raid
get stuff in there love that I don't
have 1,000 voices love that when someone
I'm like okay so here's that here's the
counter Tibet though not much else do
you want out of thousand out of last
wish out of how much more how much other
stuff you did you want out of last wish
a lot of people have issues with raid
rewards and if the only thing you want
is an exotic okay yeah you're okay that
you don't have it but have you been
trying to get it or do you just assume
yeah like there's a lot guys know yeah
for like if you have an exotic that's
really really cool and everybody wants
it cool but if you're like do I want to
run a raid with a chance just to get
that or do am I going to be getting
anything else from that raid that
benefits me whether is there a hand
cannon like faded like are there other
things in there that are worthwhile
acting like these other raid
whether they any good
we acted like like nobody know what you
know a mr. Otto röhm the one that
dropped with four times a charm and and
in you know the one Otto I forgot the
name of it in a last wish really good
I think the pulse is really good
chattering oh another bone yeah is the
threat level um what's the one that puts
the things on the inner here was it well
I mean that's another exotic yeah like
the exotics are the beige old bond is
the other yes
Thank You bender hey listen it's okay to
not have stuff is it it's part of the
lore of that is what makes destiny to me
again special those Gjallarhorn moments
when it was so hard to get but when you
got it you cherished it you cherished it
man that's when destiny is specialist in
my opinion when it's at its best with
everybody running around you know with
everything d2 vanilla launch we see what
happened
don't forget your history don't forget
you've been through all of it just
hasn't cut that way it hasn't felt that
way in a while so anyway this for a
while we'd read this one to dad probably
won't go through the narrative previews
just because those are they're cool
though read them guys kind of get a feel
of what Eris's journey is going through
what we've kind of been dealing what
she's been dealing with we got chapter
four out there recently that's dealing
with a friend in need so we're now
talking about the Dreaming city and Mara
and so those are cool final piece we got
was the twelve and they talked about the
raid belts which are cool whoo but we've
got the raid info so we know it actually
launches on a Saturday at noon I've
literally work up until noon that
morning so mm-hmm I'm not probably gonna
go for the 24 hours I don't know if it's
good I'm gonna play a lot that week so I
don't know but we have a power level for
the raid now so let's talk about it
let's did it well yeah so let me jump
right in
take it man
so look we got a they're not belts cuz
we know the big show don't like that the
whole title thing but uh anyway so yeah
contest mo y'all so on Saturday October
5th guards were venturing to the new
rate Garden of the salvation many of you
have been to the black garden before but
don't be fooled
an entirely new challenge awaits you
contest mode will be active for the
first 24 hours similar to the crown of
sorrow world's first completion while
contest is active players will face
enforced challenge to out the rape power
beyond certain levels will provide no
additional advantage for a given fight
for example for the first fight power
above 890 does it provide an advantage
and for the final fight power above 920
doesn't provide an advantage after the
24-hour period ends we will disable
contest mode and players can take full
advantage of their higher power to
overcome raised challenges as always
they're watching for you to claim the
world the prestige of being world's
first to complete the raid that prize
bragging rights of course will be that
beautiful custom-made god of salvation
world first built your totally kind of
clean I think I think about what you
feel about the belt well I mean it's
there
they're always absorbent and
over-the-top but that's kind of the idea
I mean you got the teal you got the
garden symbol which you've seen now that
kind of confirms that's the raid symbol
that we saw on the map you got the
little vex goblin down there with 20 19
in the bottom I mean they're always well
done no question so they're cool yeah so
we got to talk about this power level
we're starting at 750 we have five days
to get to basically 9:20 so 170 power
levels we know the soft cap is gonna be
nine mm-hmm and then we gotta go so
that'll get you through through the
first the soft cap will get you through
the first last five will be nine twenty
mmm-hmm
now previously we had last wish we had
last wish right so we were going ten
days so we had longer saw we started at
380 depend
if you had salsa semuc you were starting
400 and we got what was soft cap 500
back then that sound right
sounds about right five stones so then
you had powerful engrams people were
getting to five forty five fifty stuff
like that but they had a full other
weekly reset to go through they had set
they had ten days instead of five and
they were getting up to what 5 45 50 ish
somewhere in there that people were
finishing up and still struggling and
contests they'll be active anything
above nine twenty won't matter so
thinking people can get to nine twenty
but it's a bigger soft grind which I
guess I'm actually okay with cuz you're
just always been getting more stuff but
that 9:52 and some of that I don't know
when you actually start doing your power
levels I guess we'll see when the
artifact starts going into effect - yeah
and then up to nine then you got 20 for
the hard cap up there as well I don't
know what do you think do you think 170
levels is how's that gonna feel this is
a lot I mean you you nailed all the
major points I mean yes there was a
slight change with the soft cap stuff
and world drops kind of staying at level
so that won't be as bad but that's a
longer that's a grind
that's a that's intense you know that's
a lot of levels so you know we gotta see
people going that dudes gonna be like
all night and you know say like dip tier
V up this is a serious crime
I was actually no he intimidated looks
like man I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do it like this is a level of
commitment y'all you know Tuesday at
launch you know we're getting at you hit
the ground running you know I mean
granite yes everyone's gonna be at 750
from the jump of 750 to 9 2000 to be in
that final in that final fight to be 170
levels plus I mean I tweeted like be
bold Caroline gamer he was like I think
people get there and I was like I'm sure
you will
this is like
and shadow keep flu staying home from
work vacation do you guys like wigs
you got Tuesday to Wednesday Wednesday
Thursday Thursday Friday Saturday
Saturday you really only have like 96
hours yeah and you're probably gonna
need a lot of them this is intense
grinding um and they talk about first
and count all right let's just forget
about wrestle and pizza rolls thank you
black I've never had Red Bull in my I
don't like Red Bull so no good rev oh
yeah that some people go ahead to
subscribe to that bull shout-out to
5-hour energy
oh no no shout-out to Gigi gamer stops
out there gamer sucks actually
I bought two of theirs I've used that as
brie workout I've used that as yeah I've
used it for multiple different things
and I like there's no spike there's no
energy there's no tingles but honestly
like it's it's clean I really like it is
very clean
and I've tried my fair share like
sometimes I want that pre-work I got the
tingles I'm gonna go watch this kick
boxing bag cool or like if you want to
go lift same thing you're like all right
I'm going heavy today gonna take it but
it's like if you just want like I want
to like feel like feel like I'm ready
but not feel like I'm gonna jump off the
cliff ready like I'm not going too far
like yeah gamers good so shadow not
sponsored by him by the way I mean I'd
love we'd love it but you know we met so
maybe got the bag off that's all we got
for today guys that one it is over can't
return paint come back we did we took a
deal we took it did we did after yeah
yeah I mean listen you know this is this
isn't gonna be a serious grind you know
and I I like it I still like it overall
just the premise of it you know in just
a whole you know as far as far as the
contest rules as I should say be
specific concerts rules I I'm a huge fan
they had to do something you know guys
are running around you know melting
things so fast yeah I like how they yeah
I mean it establishes the difficulty for
the fight which
be good the difficulty will be where
they place it people aren't gonna over
level or if they say bounties and
they're up above doesn't matter so a lot
of that stuff won't matter I will be
very curious to see there's not gonna be
a really good way to tell but I'll be
very curious to see how much old armor
is infused up to take into the raid and
just like have mills or if anybody can
like pull it off with 2.0 yeah that's a
good point because let's be real you
know materials gonna be at a premium
yeah you know you're gonna find this
you're gonna have like no time to get
them either
exactly so like how committed do you
want to stick to those build what keep
infusing you know that those synergy
builds you know I'm saying that's
something people gonna have to make
tough decisions and then orangie is
gonna play in a play you start getting
2.0 stuff with stuff you need and you
know it's a lot of fact is it's really
interesting to see how it goes I will be
very curious how much the artifact plays
yes
if people could max that artifact and
people are poppin heavy ammo out of
enemies a lot that last tier if they can
get that last here in five days
if then artifact can get maxed out in
five days that might be the part that
breaks more than anything because you've
got the chance at the heavy ammo you've
got the void grenades doing damage
you've got a couple arc builds there's
one I don't even know and that's not
even gonna you've got enhanced reloaders
for like one energy going for builds on
armor because then you're like okay well
now do it then that'll be the test is
like does the armor 2.0 make you well
crap I don't have the perfect reload and
scavenger mechanics but I've got this
cool finisher I've got some okay I I
like I'm actually almost would really
like the artifact to get to be like
fully available if people grind hard for
it some makes people like go armor to I
want them to mean I don't know I want
the world's first team to beat it with
armor 2.0 I don't think they're going to
but I'd love to see it happen I'm torn
because um I like the idea of it I just
partly do want to grind for it though I
mean I do want there to be a grind for
artifact
cuz yeah yeah
yeah light level might help with the
artifact but like those mods man those
finished some of those big mods in the
end or yeah but that'll be it'll be a
grind I see I don't know how long those
are gonna take the level up either is it
just like is that a longer grind versus
the power level versus the Caesar me I
don't know how all those equate yeah cuz
it's like is when you get a normal
experience levels they're gonna be like
an artifact level a season ranking
everything else ores this at this speed
this over here slower your bonus power
takes longer like is everything all over
the place where different things hit at
different paces then I've really no way
to judge but I would really love to see
the artifact to be the thing that makes
people like getting a build and be like
or maybe one person goes full like I bet
it'll actually probably be split if I'm
actually gonna be smart about it some
people who know be like okay I'm going
whisper I've got my perfect sniper setup
with double scavenger perks or double
reserves I've got my scavenger perks
reloader enhanced unflinching okay I'm
going normal okay I don't have anything
amazing like that will you you need to
go armor 2.0 get your get your damn
artifact up so you're ready for that
finish up that's your grind you figure
out how to get that artifact as high as
you can the other people are gonna be
infusing one way so it's probably gonna
be a split but I could actually see some
interesting roles with that artifact I'm
really curious about the artifact and
I'm hoping I'm hoping that's actually
the whole thing that people get to use
no see man I loving it man contest rules
will be in effect we got the 24 hour
thing that it's going to end and then
everybody can take advantage of what
they got to do shout out to the rules
though did you see did you get it you
feel like I looked before at the rules
like yo if you swap your man out oh that
I know yeah yeah it is like it's just
whoever finishes that last bit up yeah
yeah we only the people finish so if
that your man got all that we got you
there he got you ain't getting no belt
they are going to not have a sad for
detto moment again because the exotic
there will not be an exotic drop from
the final encounter no guaranteed
winning team exotic drop where they both
got it quick and then they turned it off
it's going to be
so that makes me wonder isn't gonna be
more raid exotic quest or is it just
gonna be orangey do you think it's just
an orangey exotic or do you think like
the raid exotic would be more like touch
of malice where it's a quest and path to
go through versus like it's a drop at
the end I think what God says maybe to
keep it dropped my guess is they keep a
drop you know just for um you know the
the keep they want that engagement they
want coming back why didn't you try
again I think they love that a love all
that stuff which emblem by the way which
emblem do you like more the 24-hour or
the everyone the 24-hour can go on a
bush is that everyone a nice with you
man like the 2400 would be late it'd be
epic to have it but that another one
looks like it looks nice yeah like a
little 3d box thing going on I'm trying
to figure out what is the exclusive what
I mean what is that
so basic take it like almost what I'm
seeing it is cuz always in the
background of the black garden you have
this like kind of mountainous plateau in
the background okay and it's like kind
of the line drawings because you see
kind of the kind of caverns and chasms
and stuff that are through the black
garden it's all just drawn and like kind
of Tron green outline right that's kind
of what I see it as is like a plateau
and the canyons around it it's just not
the most obvious but that's what I can
kind of at least pull from it other than
that so they are fixing the little apply
bug which is worse on PC thank God yeah
you want to apply this thing you're like
come on come on already and do you get
the glitch where you try to choose a
destination and it gets like timed out
or something like you can't like select
you get that - oh yeah you can't launch
yep yeah I don't know if that's similar
to this but I guess we'll just have to
see other than that there's a lot of
details about PC migration everything
like that what isn't isn't available if
you're in the whole world of PC it all
go read it I'm not gonna break it down
right now but they just talk about steam
one thing about this though on Twitter
they have heard a whole lot of people up
in arms asking for pre download and they
said they are looking into that so that
is a big one because otherwise you're
gonna have October 1st at noon
smashing desti servers with new light
and everybody you want like no that'd be
awful you'd be like me make them PS yeah
ps4 players would be like yeah they're
like we just got a copy our servers
still up at least though download that
that's got to get set up I'm surprised
that hasn't been a thing but they they
are at least they mentioned it I saw it
on Twitter so it's out there I just I
don't care if it's a day one little baby
patch but we can't be downloading like
whatever it is on top because we're
probably gonna have to redownload the
whole game because it's gonna be like
the Steam download whatever works with
that who knows but yeah I think that
free download even just give me 24 hours
just to put it on you gotta do that cuz
and then people will be paid it's not
yeah and people trying to get raid
written you know that big ones are on PC
too they got to go like so yeah they got
a pre download and be like and go like
yeah you got to be able to loot and log
on long a shot of the PC stuff is do it
if you ain't finished first so you can
finish it is you getting reset and then
keep in mind that once you get poured it
over that you might not have access to
forsake stuff initially as the migration
is still going on
that's pretty much the gist of it you
know what with the migration map so get
it done get your silver and all that
taken care of you got codes use your
codes please yeah you get it done you
lose it but that pretty much wraps up to
12 and most everything shout out to dmg
by the way Dillon out there he had to
get had it was like atrial fib or
something like that had people
restarting a serger so 30 thoughts out
there to him he's in recovery right now
so Cosmo took over but Dillon damage
whatever you go by our thoughts are with
you man hopefully the ticker gets back
to working properly gotta keep you back
in the community so take your recovery
time we'll be here
watch from afar watch the raid raise
from your couch and we'll see you soon
health is wealth and heal up man glad
did you take care of yourself and I need
you around very cool do we got a chance
to meet him at a guardian car now oh
yeah great nice guy man nice guy maybe
had a brain suit on it oh my god yeah
twice I think I've seen my red suit
yeah he's got he's full-on bred costume
and he's like dude you have no idea how
sweaty this is that's good good dude
viens Elias I heal up we will see you
soon but other than that it's about all
we got I know he rambled on for a bit we
had our we had our tussle we had
arguments as always that's why and from
what I can tell in to our stream zero
dropped frames
yes also like the internet loves again
because you were suffering out there I
feel for you man that's good man I'll
get my boy even let him do what he needs
to do in a net so as the Internet is now
reliable I've got some guests we want to
work on we know October 11th so the week
at that the right day or the 10th I
gotta look calendar mm scare oh he was
on before it'll be the truffle scare oh
no at 11th yeah that's right the Friday
scare oh he was on before great guy go
check out his YouTube channel hilarious
stuff nice dude we want to get him back
on because previous last word man
himself but great weekend is gonna be
crazy for a lot of people so that one's
gonna be tight timing wise for a lot
yeah
but scary we've got he will definitely
be coming for sure and then outside of
that got quite a few more a lot of these
will likely be in the evenings though so
yes
follow on twitter both myself kognito
and last word pod if we do a time change
for a guest most of the guests we're
looking at are gonna be evening time so
like a Friday night 6 p.m. 7 p.m. 5 p.m.
something like that depending on your
timezone it'll be more of an evening
stream which may help for some
suspending one who wants to watch but I
think many we're looking at so stay
tuned on Twitter for times I will make a
big like try and make it as obvious as I
can everywhere if that changes other
than that if it's us you guys know will
typically be here unless things change
but that's all I got what do you got
coming make them short and sweet we're
already two and a half hours yeah we're
two and a half we get out here yeah man
you already know you don't own the
Twitter and iron law podcast on YouTube
big Sunday we have
have a new guest debut will be n64 Josh
let's talk about what's very cool yeah
yeah whoa guy man cool guy got a chance
to meet him we'll be talking about
everything that's going on well it will
be the Tendo will get a lot of stuff
going on but we also will be talking
about all the latest stuff going on with
Sony Microsoft and all the rest so
please check that out and of course you
know on all the youngest yeah the odd
rumor that's out there is like that's
different
that's different yeah yeah so please
check us out we have that you know and
also have like I said I'm on iron law
podcast Channel please check out king of
the statues if you went to marble
statues all that good stuff and of
course you know I'm saying stream team
and of course over here we have the last
word you can also catch as well every
Friday you already know the deal you
know I'm saying
so you please support and last but not
least thank you for all the support for
Lords of gaming dotnet the articles that
we put up the team we're trying to
construct oh I gotta I got a plug please
if you like lore even if you don't like
my articles forget about if you like
lore check out my boy Josh reading who
we had on last word podcast at one point
this guy has some tremendous called the
shadow key primer series he's got some
tremendous lore to get you ready for
shadow keep for each race he's breaking
it all down it's a series check it out
man it's really great stuff if you can
definitely guys check that one out oh he
likes it I'm good no seriously like it's
good stuff yeah he's good um for me guys
we're gonna go read drew ski here in a
second so say hey to him for me met him
at Guardian Con as well very cool dude
do not want to face them in PvP so just
go watch enjoy but for me and see boxes
everywhere my internet is back so I will
be trying to stream more since it seems
reliable across your fingers at holds
I'm just glad it happened now as opposed
to a week and a half from now so timing
works I guess yeah II bought this
everywhere twitch Twitter and YouTube
subscribe like follow all the good
things and for this week it is episode
74 we are wrapping this thing up so
thank you guys September 20th we are
done
enjoy your weekend your grind and it has
been the last word